Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On va
vous faire les présentations vite fait.
Benjamin Bayard, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Alexis Fidjan au Cofé, bonsoir.
Pourquoi vous êtes là ce soir ? Qui
êtes-vous ?
Ah ! [soupir][souffle coupé]
On est là pour vous parler des exégettes
amateurs.
C'est quoi les exégettes ?
Euh,
je te laisse faire le brief.
C'est un collectif de défense des
libertés numériques qui s'est formé il y
a quelques années, qui regroupe des
juristes et des ingénieurs et qui
essayent de défendre nos nos libertés
fondamentales sur internet.
C'est quoi des libertés fondamentales
sur internet ? Ah, c'est une grande
question ça.
Euh, c'est difficile à définir. C'est
des libertés particulièrement
importantes qui
existe dans la sphère numérique.
Quoi des exemples ? Benjamin Alexis,
des trucs simples en fait. Si tu
regardes ce que font la majorité des
gens qui agissent autour du d'Internet,
ils font du business et ils défendent le
business et les libertés du business. Le
droit d'entreprendre, la liberté de
maltraiter les gens pour faire du fric
du business.
[grognement]
Nous ce qui nous intéresse, c'est pas
ça. Ce qui nous intéresse, c'est au
contraire euh défendre les droits des
gens. Euh le droit à la vie privée,
c'est une liberté fondamentale. Euh le
droit de pas s'auto-incriminer quand tu
es accusé par la justice, c'est tu vois,
aux États-Unis, c'est le 5e amendement.
Le droit à la liberté d'expression,
c'est aussi une liberté fondamentale.
Euh le fait qu'on puisse pas te censurer
sans passer par un juge, le fait qu'on
puisse pas te priver d'une de tes
libertés sans passer par un juge. C'est
des trucs qui sont dans les fondamentaux
de la société depuis à peu près de
siècles. C'est des des trucs qui ont été
en gros à peu près imposés pendant la
révolution. Euh
celle de 1789.
Celle 93,
c'est autre chose. 93, c'est plus
intéressant.
Euh
et donc si tu veux ces morceaux-là sous
prétexte que ça se passe sur internet,
c'est remis en cause. Mais c'est super
courant. Ça fait 20 ans à peu près que
nos politiciens font ça. Euh un truc qui
est évident dans la vie de tous les
jours du genre je sais pas tu fais pas
interdire un journal sans passer par un
juge. C'est pas un policier qui décide,
c'est un juge. [bâillement]
Ça paraît complètement évident. Tu vas
avoir n'importe quel politicien des
années 90 et tu lui dis "On veut faire
interdire un journal juste sur décision
de la police". Si tu fais "Ah non, c'est
les États, c'est les dictatures qui font
ça, c'est pas les États démocratiques."
Mais sur internet, il est d'accord pour
le faire juste parce qu'il a pas piné
que le numérique c'est du monde normal,
sauf qu'il est numérique au lieu d'être
en papier. Etth et en fait bah depuis 3
ans, ça existe les exégètes amateurs et
on
en fait on essaie de défendre ce qu'on
peut euh si tu veux. C'est une suite
logique du travail associatif qu'on a
fait par ailleurs.
Comment vous êtes financé ? On
n'est pas financé, on est tous
bénévoles. C'est tout bénévole en fait.
Le le plus gros financement des
exégettes, c'est moi quand je paye les
courriers recommandés.
Tu vois, ça fait 10 balles de temps en
temps, c'est pas cher à recommander.
Donc, on vous a fait venir aujourd'hui
tous les deux euh pour parler de trois
dossiers qu'on qu'on [grognement] a
abordé un peu en interne et on avait
besoin de de vos de vos lumières. Euh,
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler de du
fameux Orange Fail ? Est-ce que ça vous
parle ? Est-ce que vous pouvez rentrer
un peu dans les détails en étant
pédagogique en expliquant les tenu des
about historique.
Alors, qui commence ?
Vas-y, commence par le début.
Alors, l'histoire du truc parce que ça
remonte loin en fait. Le Orange fail
Orange 2
euh Orange Télécom les les marchands de
réseau. Euh ça commence par les décrets
2015 125 et 2015 si je me trompe pas.
Alors, ouais, je précise tout de suite
parce que je sais qu'il y a des gens
chez vous qui font du fact checking
sur Capitaine Fact. Tous nosiers sont en
ligne. Exeget.org
Toutes nos écritures sont en ligne. À
chaque fois qu'on a écrit des mémoires
sur une affaire, qu'on a envoyé un texte
au Conseil d'État, tout est en ligne.
Les PDF sont en ligne pour qu'il puisse
être lus et pour qu'il puisse être
utilisé par des gens qui voudraient
faire comme nous pour montrer comment on
fait. Euh donc ça commence par le décret
2015 et le décret 2015 qui sont pris en
application euh de loi qui instaure la
censure sur décision de la police pour
les sites euh pédophiles ou terroristes
ou le dééférencement sur décision de la
police pour les sites pédo hétérro.
Et donc quand les quand les décrets
d'application sont publiés, on les
attaque euh en considérant que ben
voilà, il respecte pas les les libertés
fondamentales parce que euh entre
autres, il y a il y a tout un tas de
problèmes que nous on y voit. Euh et un
des points qu'on soulève euh c'est un
truc très précis. Le décret prévoit
quelque chose qui est pas prévu par la
loi qui est quand un site est bloqué
parce que le la l'équipe spécialisée de
la police considère que c'est un site
terroriste ou un site pédophile, euh les
internautes sont renvoyés sur une page
web qui est hébergée sur un serveur du
ministère de l'intérieur.
Et sur ce point-là, moi ça me hérisse le
poil parce que je fais non, ça il y a
pas moyen. Ça veut dire qu'ils vont
avoir des logs. C'est qu'ils vont avoir
les logs du site web. Donc ils auront
les IP des gens. Donc ils vont
Si c'est un site pédo c'est normal. Mais
non, mais non, c'est pas normal. Tu as
pas le droit de ficher les gens, c'est
comme ça. Tu as pas le droit de ficher
les gens sur décision de la police et
surtout, tu as pas le droit de
constituer un fichier de police sans
qu'il soit autorisé, sans qu'il y ait un
avis de l'accil, sans qu'il enf il y a
tout un formalisme pour créer un
fichier, pour ficher les gens, il y a un
formalisme.
Euh et donc nous, on signale ça dans les
dans les moyens qu'on soulève dans
contre contre le décret. On perd et le
Conseil d'État si tu veux, j'ai la
décision du Conseil d'État là nous
répond dans le truc sur lequel on perd
en nous disant bien le décret ne prévoit
pas explicitement la création d'un
fichier. Donc le décret n'est pas
illégal.
En tant qu'informaticien, je sais que
c'est con parce que le fichier existera
forcément. Je tu mets un serveur web qui
répond une page, il y a un de
fichier qui donne les log quoi. C'est
pas possible. C'est jamais on configure
100 m de fichier de log. Enfin, il y a
que quelques paranos euh qui font ça. Et
donc, on sait qu'il y aura ce fichierlà.
Et puis quelques mois plus tard euh
Orange dans sa façon d'implémenter le
filtrage en question
fail,
il se gour et il renvoie sur le le site
du ministère de l'intérieur tout Google,
tout Wikipédia et deux trois bricoles.
On sait pas ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs concrètement côté orange, on
a jamais on a on a jamais vu su
exactement qu'est-ce qui s'était passé,
comment est-ce que ce cet échec a été
mis en place, enfin qu'est-ce qui a été
produit pour qu'il y ait ce fail assez
énorme. mon enfin à ma connaissance, je
sais pas s'il y a eu un communiqué d'or,
je crois pas euh je me souviens plus
mais en tout cas enfin pas pas détaillé,
je crois qu'il ont communiqué sur oups,
on a réparé mais
[grognement] ils nous ont pas dit quoi
quoi. Et alors ce qui était ce qui était
assez amusant euh just lors de cette
donc redirection euh donc de tout le
trafic euh tous les abonnés qui étaient
chez Orange pendant une journée ou un
petit peu moins d'une journée, tous les
abonnés chez Orange qui souhaitaient se
connecter à Google, Wikipédia ou tout un
tas d'autres sites, mais déjà Google et
Wikipédia, ça génère quand même un
trafic très important, ont été redirigés
donc vers cette page du
ministère de l'intérieur qui était là
normalement pour avertir les internautes
qui tentaient d'accéder à un contenu qui
était illicite et en ce Ce qui est assez
amusant, c'est que comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer, les serveurs du ministère de
l'intérieur n'étaient pas dimensionnés
pour recevoir un trafic aussi important.
Donc en l'espace de quelques minutes,
ils ont été mis hors ligne, hors service
et c'est là que ça devient comique.
Tout le monde sait que il y a des logs
qui sont produits. Donc la presse en
ligne commence à gueuler sur vous vous
rendez pas compte de ce que ça fait, ça
fiche tout le monde. Et en réponse le
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
qui s'appelle
Bernard Casneu si
c'était encore Casneu à l'époque euh
fait un communiqué de presse disant
"J'ai demandé au prestataires d'effacer
les logues d'hier
donc la main dans le sac." Donc le
ministre reconnaissait officiellement
qu'il y avait un traitement de données
personnelles avec des des logues qui
étaient enregistrés et donc qu'il avait
demandé au prestateur de les effacer
pour rassurer les gens. Mais en voulant
rassurer comme ça la population, il
avouait qu'en réalité ce traitement
existait. Et nous ce traitement-là
c'était une des choses qu'on mettait en
avant lorsqu'on avait attaqué ces ces
décrets devant le conseil d'État.
Et le conseil d'État nous avait répondu
comme Jamin a dit que les textes qu'on
attaquait ne permettaient pas la mise en
place de ce traitement. Ce qui ne veut
pas forcément dire que d'autres textes
ne permettent pas, mais en tout cas
c'est ces décrets-là ne le mettaient
pas. Donc ce qu'on a fait une fois qu'on
a eu ce ce communiqué de de presse, donc
il reconnaissait l'existence de ce
traitement. Donc on a considéré que
derrière il y avait l'existence d'une
décision administrative qui avait mis en
place ce traitement. Parce qu'il faut
bien comprendre que lorsqu'on essaie
d'attaquer en content administratif, il
faut qu'on attaque une décision
administrative. Ça peut être un arrêté,
ça peut être un décret, mais il faut que
ça soit une décision administrative.
Donc on a considéré que cette décision
administrative, peu importe si elle
existait matériellement, c'est-à-dire
peu importe s'il y avait un acte qui
s'appelait mise en place du
de Big Brower
de voilà exactement enfin du traitement
en cause, on considérait que
implicitement elle avait été prise et
donc on a demandé au ministre d'abroger
cette décision. Alors abroger ça veut
dire
de la retirer si vous voulez pour pour
dire les choses simplement. C'est un
retrait mais qui qui n'est valable que
pour l'avenir. C'est l'abrogation. C'est
ça. Donc on a demandé au ministre de la
Brogé. Non, on a demandé directement au
conseil d' Ah non, on a demandé
directement au Conseil d'État. Non,
celui-là on a demandé c'est sur la
rétention des données qu'on est qu'on a
fait une demande d'abrogation. Il me
semble qu'on l'a fait directement le
conseil d'état celle-là.
Laisse le terminer.
Ah, c'est je sais plus on a on a
considéré que c'était le communiqué de
presse qui révélait et que on avait on
avait on était bon sur les de mois de
délais. Tu as raison. Je crois qu'on a
fait [grognement] comme ça.
Effectivement. Ouais. On a bon je crois
que j'ai les documents pour vérifier. Je
comprends avec rattention. Oui,
effectivement, on a considéré que la
décision existait en elle-même
et donc on a attaqué directement. Il
faudrait qu'on vérifie quand même ce
pointl, j'ai un doute mais peu importe.
Bon, ça c'est la procédure, on s'en
toujours est-il qu'on est allé devant
devant le Conseil d'État en demandant au
Conseil d'État d'annuler la décision qui
avait été révélée par ce communiqué de
presse. Et l'affaire est en cours. On a
eu la défense du gouvernement il y a
quelques mois et on est en train
justement de de répondre. Tu veux
peut-être parler un peu plus de la
défense ?
Ouais. Alors ça c'est ça c'est le côté
qui devient
qui devient comique si tu veux. Euh le
Conseil d'État nous a répondu il ne peut
pas y avoir de fichier puisque le décret
ne le prévoit pas et que donc le décret
est légal.
Le ministre dans le communiqué de presse
nous dit "Il y a un fichier et j'ai
demandé au prestataire d'effacer les
données d'hier."
Donc on attaque et dans sa dans sa
défense le ministère nous répond tout
est son contraire. il nous répond
"Je caricature à peine." Alors, c'est
dommage parce que ça j'ai pas le droit,
on n pas le droit de le publier. C'est
pas nous qui avons écrit ce texte là,
donc on peut pas le mettre en ligne. Ce
que le ministère nous répond
"Il n'existe pas de fichier, la preuve,
on ne s'en sert que pour faire des
stats."
[grognement]
OK.
Il nous explique euh "Pours, c'est pas
grave et donc il y a pas besoin
d'autorisation."
plus drôle. Là, pour le coup, c'est
vraiment un bout de droit qui est super
rigolo. Le ministère cite dans dans sa
défense l'article de la loi informatique
et liberté qui dit dans quel cas les
pouvoirs publics peuvent mettre en place
un fichier et que il peut y avoir un
fichier avec des données personnelles,
tout ça, tout ça, pour sécurité
nationale, pour prévenir les
infractions, pour et cetera, pour et
cetera. Si tu veux, dans la liste, il y
a pas pour faire des stades d'audience,
ça y est pas.
C'est Balou. Et la conclusion de de du
juriste du ministère qui a écrit ça,
c'est vu que c'est pas dans la liste, on
avait pas demandé la permission.
C'est
c'est très poétique en fait en droit ce
truc.
C'est c'est et j'ai une question
d'internet là. On a une question
d'internet. N'est-ce pas nécessaire de
conserver des logs de sites
ter et pédo ? C'est pas le problème. Si
c'est nécessaire ce qui reste à prouver,
d'abord, c'est très très peu utile parce
que tu vas tu vas tomber euh pour les
pour les sites péo en fait, tu vas
tomber sur des gens qui sont en train de
regarder du porn et qui se font attrapés
par des pubs et des rebonds et des
machins et des pop-up et des c'est pas
très intéressant. Il y a une pop-up qui
met un gros logo ministère de
l'intérieur, site web interdit. Donc ça
fait très très peur. Mais c'est tout. Je
tuas tu as rien attraper du tout avec
ça. Je tu vas tu vas en discuter avec
les gens qui font vraiment de la chasse
aux pédophiles. Euh moi j'ai discuté de
ce genre de sujet avec Éric Fressinet à
l'époque où il bossait encore à l'IRCGN.
Euh leur colonel de gendarmerie
spécialisé sur tout ce qui est cyber,
défense, attaque, criminalité numérique
et cetera. et il explique non ça ça
c'est pas très intéressant
on va pas traiter ça. [grognement] Donc
ça présente pas un intérêt stratégique
très fort mais surtout pour être fait il
doit y avoir des règles. C'estd que la
loi dit c'est ces sites là il faut telle
et telle et telle formalité il faut que
ce soit prévu. Il faut qu'il y ait un
avis de l'accilit
il y a des règles. Tu peux pas le faire
comme ça en cowboy.
Bon revenons à notre sujet. Donc quand
vous comme vous les avez pris la main
dans le pot de confiture, ils se sont
justifiés comment ?
Ce que je viens de te dire, [grognement]
le fichier n'existe pas. D'ailleurs, on
ne fait que des statistiques avec. Ça se
résume à ça.
C'est défendable, monsieur l'avocat
en fait. Non, c'est pas défendable. Et
puis ils expliquaient que à supposer
même que le fichier existe et ce que
disait Bin justement là à l'instant
c'est que dans tous les cas à partir du
moment où le le cas n'était pas prévu
par la par la loi informatique et
liberté bien ils avaient pas ils
savaient pas à mettre en place à
demander l'autorisation à l'nil ou à
mettre en place un un système légal
autour de ça et ça pour le coup c'est en
droit c'est très critiquable donc on
verra ce que le conseil d'état nous dira
ça je je peux pas trop m'avancer sur
nous on estime qu'on a des arguments
quand même assez solides parce que par
moment où où il y a un régime qui vient
encadrer l'utilisation le traitement la
collecte et de enfin tout ce qui touche
les les données personnelles et qui
vient soumettre ça à des autorisations
de préalable de l'acné qui vient
soumettre ça à des conditions à un
encadrement fort. On peut pas considérer
qu'à partir du moment où les exceptions
qui sont mises en place ne ne prévoient
pas un cas qu'on euh qu'on souhaite
mettre en avant, mettre en place, que
euh dans ces conditions, on est on
serait qu'on serait en dehors de toute
tout contrôle juridique, de tout toute
toute procédure légale et et
réglementaire.
Donc euh pour le coup, nos arguments
sont quand même en en pur droit assez
forts. Après bon, on verra ce que ce qui
nous ce qui sera jugé, mais on on n'est
pas du tout sur un notre recours est
solide. Enfin, il est on a on il est
sérieux. Faut comprendre comment
fonctionne la loi informatique et
liberté. Elle dit il est interdit de
ficher les gens. Point. Par exception,
la puissance publique peut pour certains
motifs légitimes ficher les gens.
Les motifs légitimes sont plaf plaf plaf
plaf plaf plaf sécurité nationale
criminalité grave et cetera et cetera et
la procédure pour mettre en place un tel
fichier est plaf plaf plaf plaf plaf et
les règles. Et ce que nous répond le le
ministre c'est comme on n'est pas dans
les cas d'exception prévu on s'en fout
d'appliquer la loi. Il y a pas besoin.
À mon sens c'est parfaitement faux. Mais
et en plus enfin ce qui est important là
dans dans ce que vient de dire Benjamin,
c'est que en il y a un principe général
en droit dans tout tout le type de droit
que ce soit droit civil, droit pénal,
droit administratif dans toutes les
domaines du droit, il y a le principe
général de l'interprétation stricte des
exceptions. Ça veut dire qu'à partir du
moment où on vient poser un principe, il
faut que les exceptions à ce principe
soient interprété strictement. Sinon, ça
revient à remettre en cause le l'essence
même du principe. Et donc là, on est un
petit peu dans ce C'est pas tout à fait
on touche pas tout à fait à ce cas-là,
mais il faut bien conserver ça en tête
lorsqu'on aborde ce problème, c'est que
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas nous dire
que à partir du moment où le principe
c'est l'interdiction et que ce qu'on
souhaite faire et n n'est pas pris n'est
pas prévu par les exceptions, c'est un
contresens de considérer que c'est
autorisé dans ces conditions. Orange
peut être attaqué pour peut être
responsable. Non, c'est pas
non Orange, ils ont juste fait une
panne. C'est pas grave.
Enfin, c'est c'est pas not
c'est pas eux qui mettent les gens en
fiche.
Et puis c'est pas du tout l'objet de
notre cours. L'objet de notre cours,
c'est simple, c'est un objet au niveau
un petit peu méta. Euh ce qu'on ce qu'on
essaie de mettre en avant, c'est que euh
il y a des procédures qui doivent être
respectées. Il y a un encadrement
juridique qui doit être respecté. L'état
de droit, c'est ça.
Est-ce que vous avez communiqué autour
de ça, mis à part sur votre petit site
internet ou près de votre petite
communauté, est-ce qu'il y a des
journalistes qui sont venus emboitter le
pas ? pour dire voilà l'État est en
train de ficher des gens sans sans des
dispositions juridiques légales. Il y a
eu il y a eu un petit peu ça a fait un
peu un remou ou tout le monde s'en fout
je je me souviens plus exactement dans
le détail. Je sais qu'à l'époque le en
tout cas le ce fail avait a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre sur tout un tas de
journaux en ligne et papier. Euh nous on
en a également parlé bon via nos outils
de communication habituelle et on a fait
quelques petites conférences dans des
événements mais c'est vrai que ça touche
quand même un public assez averti déjà.
En dehors de ça, je sais pas si tu t'as
tuas souvenir de d'article écrit
pas en test.
Ça n'a pas dépassé la presse numérique
que ça a fait du next impact du numérama
des choses comme ça mais ça n'a ça n'a
pas tellement dépassé la presse écrite.
Si la presse grand public en a parlé
comme étant une panne majeure d'orange.
Ah bah tranquille
mais
pas tellement sur l'aspect euh
illégal. La moitié de la population
française s'est retrouvé fichier de
manière parfaitement illégale.
Je vois que tu as sorti des petits
papiers.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est dans les dans les
éléments de réponse que nous a envoyer
le ministère, il y a des il y a des
bribes que j'ai envie de te lire. il
mettent en annexe. Alors je je donne pas
les noms et malheureusement ça on peut
pas le publier parce que c'est le
mémoire en défense. Nous on l'a parce
qu'on est la partie qui attaque et donc
on a tu as le droit de le communiquer
juste comme ça.
Justement je vais enlever certains mots
dans les phrases.
Euh donc c'est un mail euh
envoyé
par quelqu'un du ministère qui répond
manifestement à sa direction qui on lui
demande de préparer la défense du
ministère.
Et donc il ou elle dit euh en revanche
mais sous réserve de confirmation par
cette dernière, il semblerait que la
direction machin qui héberge les page de
renvoi du dispositif de blocage et
transmet les volumétries globales
mentionnées Supra collecte ses adresses
IP mais uniquement à des fins
statistiques et ce pour l'ensemble des
sites hébergant les pages de renvoi.
Selon les informations communiquées par
cette direction, elle utiliserait en
effet pour administrer les pages de
renvoi le logiciel libre AWSTA stat.
C'est bien, ils utilisent du libre euh
qui permet entre autres de calculer bla
bla bla bla bla bla donc [grognement] le
nombre de hits, le nombre de pages vues,
enfin toutes ces bêtises habituelles de
paragraphes plus loin. Les données sont
stockées pendant 1 an sur des
environnements isolés et protégés
redondés et ne sont accessibles que par
les personnels concernés de cette
direction, tous fonctionnaires et
assermentés. Donc non seulement ils nous
disent que le fichier existe celui dont
nous parlons euh mais qu'il est en plus
sur des serveurs renondés pour pas qu'il
se perd.
plus rigolo. Dans le reste du mémoire,
le ministre de l'intérieur nous parle
du fait qu'il fait faire des stades
d'audience par Xi.
C'estd que sur le site web du ministère,
tu as pour les gens qui connaissent pas,
XTI, c'est un petit mécano avec des tags
où en fait tuas tu as un bidule
invisible dans la page, genre une image
d'un pixel sur un pixel transparent et
où en fait à chaque fois que ton
navigateur fait un get sur l'image pour
l'afficher, XI a toutes les infos de
quelle page tu étais en train de
regarder et puis avec tout ça, ils
crunchent tout ça et ils font des beaux
graphiques pour envoyer au ministère.
Alors, c'est vachement pratique parce
que ça permet de mesurer l'audience des
communiqués de presse du ministre,
savoir si l'interview du ministre à la
télévision a été bien reçu, si ça a été
cité, quels journaux ont mis des liens
vers les pages du ministère et cetera et
cetera. Puis ça vient aussi du travail
plus sérieux sur le site de la direction
juridique machin, le site de la
direction de c, le site de la direction
de ça, ça marche, ça marche pas et
cetera. Donc ça fait des audiences
marketing d'un site corporate si tu
veux, d'un site institutionnel.
Là, c'est pas du tout la même chose. La
page sur laquelle on renvoie, c'est la
page de sites qui ont été bloqués dans
un cadre qui est quand même très
différent de la communication publique.
L'air de rien, ça veut dire que Xiti
reçoit les noms de domaines qui sont
bloqués. Quand tu vas surah.poporne.fr
et tu tombes dessus par accident, XTI a
le nom du domaine sur lequel tu t'es
pointé dans ces logs. Donc en fait la
liste des domaines bloqués qui est
secrète, elle est communiquée à Exity.
Elle est pas si secrète que ça. Alors,
là, il y a une vraie question. C'estàd
que euh ce que ce que dit le ministre
quand il parle de ça, c'est "J'ai quand
même le droit de faire des stades."
D'ailleurs, ce fichier-là est déclaré à
la KNIL. Oui. Alors, je pense que dans
la déclaration KNIL, il parle de mesures
d'audience sur un site marketing parce
que c'est la déclaration
générique de XI pour la totalité de ses
clients. [grognement] Il parle pas du
tout de d'affaires sensibles et de sites
bloqués pour cause de terrorisme. Enfin,
tu vois. Alors, je comprends bien votre
démarche de les attaquer parce qu'ils
sont en dehors de la loi et que c'est
pas normal. Euh, est-ce qu'ils ont
peut-être voulu bien faire à votre avis
?
C'est-à-dire
bah c'est-à-dire choper des péos et des
teros.
Mais en fait, on revient ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure.
Est-ce que vous êtes pas un peu trop dur
avec eux ? Je fais l'avocat du diable.
Il y a il y a deux choses.
La loi, c'est moi.
Ce qui Non non non, ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que ce que ce qu'on attaque
là, on est on n'est pas en train de
d'essayer de comment dire de réduire un
néant les efforts pour la lutte qu'on se
enfin
ces luttesl sont parfaitement légitimes.
Et c'est c'est pas la question en
réalité. La question c'est dans quelles
conditions est-ce que ces ces ces luttes
doivent être mises en place et dans
quelles conditions est-ce que euh l'État
euh et les services de police peuvent
agir, quels sont leurs droits, quels
sont leurs pouvoirs ? C'est ça en
réalité la question. Déjà en matière de
enfin tout ce qui est justement de de
censure administrative, il y a quand
même un problème, c'est que normalement
dans un état de droit, dans une
démocratie, lorsque vous voulez censurer
l'expression de quelqu'un, il faut
l'intervention d'un juge. Pourquoi ?
pour qu'il puisse vérifier que ça rentre
bien dans les conditions qui sont posées
par la loi et qui et que vous n'essayez
pas au lieu de censurer quelque chose
qui est parfaitement légitime de de
faire terire un opposant politique ou
peu importe autre chose. Et aujourd'hui,
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui, il faut
bien comprendre comment ça fonctionne.
une administration qui vient fixer une
liste de sites qui est mise à jour
régulièrement dont elle voit cette liste
ensuite à Orange et aux autres
fournisseurs d'accès internet et Orange
et les autres fournisseurs accès
internet font ensuite le blocage au
niveau du DNS en mettant à jour cette
liste. Et c'est d'ailleurs peut-être
lors d'une mise à jour, il y a peut-être
une confusion des listes. Enfin, on sait
pas ce qui s'est passé dans le cas
d'Orange cheville.
Mais du coup, c'est vraiment c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne. Donc ça veut dire
que c'est une administration dont on ne
connaît pas. La décision n'est pas
publique. Il y a quand même un principe
fondamental dans notre droit, c'est de
publier euh en tout cas au moins les
jugements et de manière générale enfin
les les décrets, les arrêtés qui sont
pris, les actes administratifs qui sont
pris, sauf exception bien entendu. Euh
mais ça le principe c'est que cette
liste n'est pas publique. On ne sait pas
qui enfin quels sont les processus de
décision interne, qui décide de tel site
est considéré comme terroriste, tel
autre ne l'est pas. Parfois, en réalité,
il faut bien comprendre que euh la
distinction n'est pas claire, elle est
elle est floue. La définition du
terrorisme d'ailleurs n'est pas définie
de manière très précise dans nos textes.
On a plusieurs définitions. Euh il y a
des définitions dans le code pénal, il y
a des définitions au niveau
international. Parfois, elles se elles
recouvrent pas tout à fait les mêmes les
mêmes cas. Et puis ensuite, il faut bien
vérifier que les
actes en cause rentrent bien dans cette
qualification de terrorisme. Et ça,
c'est le travail d'un juge normalement.
Le juge, il est là pour vérifier que tel
ou tel acte rentre dans le champ
d'application de tel ou tel texte et de
telle ou telle infraction qui est
définie.
Et le régime qui est mise en place, ce
n'est pas ça. Le régime qui est mise en
place, c'est une administration qui
décide de manière complètement obscure.
Un peu comme à Vichi, non ?
Alors, je je
j'aime pas forcément les parallèles un
peu un peu faciles, mais enfin là où il
y a du vrai de dans cette comparaison,
c'est que on est quand même dans un dans
un système où le juge est mis à part euh
tel que le régime est pensé.
Si si je permets-moi de te couper. C'est
un peu comme si François Hollande à
l'époque envoyait des gens exécuter des
Français en Afrique ou en Syrie sans les
faire passer devant un juge. C'est ça
non ? Le le enfin le parallèle est
clairement beaucoup trop
euh je dirais presque enfin un peu
grossier, on va dire.
Bah il prend il prend il prend des
largesses avec la loi.
Oui mais c'est pas on est quand même sur
de on est sur la censure de la liberté
d'expression. On n'est pas sur sur des
cas, c'est éminemment important. C'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on se bat. Mais de
là à faire, je pense que le parallèle
est un peu
un peu dur.
Il est il est un peu dur et il est euh
je dire l'air de rien en bloquant un
site web, tu tues pas des gens. Euh
c'est quand même une différence. Euh
mais surtout c'est pas une opération
ponctuelle.
Et oui, quand il quand ils envoient des
commandos tuer quelqu'un dans des
opérations spéciales, c'est une
opération ponctuelle. Euh je t'assure
que si ça se faisait de manière
régulière en France euh dans les rues,
ce serait pas complètement la même
ambiance. Et du coup ça ne se fait pas.
Ça peut se faire sur quelques opérations
spéciales, une ou deux fois l en visant
bien, en ciblant bien.
Des exemples non ?
Ah les exemples les plus connus sont
russes. Tu sais c'est le classique
monsieur qui a glissé sur son balcon et
qui attention avec les les exécutions
russes en ce moment. Mais le le point
là-dedans, il y a il y a vraiment deux
gros éléments. On a supprimé le juge.
Or, la séparation des pouvoirs, c'est
quand même
c'est dans les c'est dans les droits de
l'homme depuis 1789, hein. Un pays où
les où les pouvoirs ne sont pas qui ne
garantit pas la séparation des pouvoirs
n'a pas de constitution. c'est que la
Constitution est nulle si elle ne
garantit pas la séparation des pouvoirs.
Et donc le fait que la police puisse se
décider toute seule d'une privation de
liberté sans passer par la justice,
c'est une atteinte manifeste
à la séparation des pouvoirs. Ça peut ça
peut arriver mais en général sur des
urgences et il y a un juge qui passe
derrière juste derrière. Typiquement
quand tu es mis quand tu es mis en garde
à vue, le juge intervient juste après.
Question d'internet. Alors, elle est un
peu longue. La réglementation européenne
permet de demander une colc un
collecteur de données et de récupérer
définitivement nos données sous un
format compréhensible. Est-ce également
possible pour le data broker Experian
Axiome, Equifax ou bientôt c'est
mal écrit encore. Bien a-t-on perdu le
contrôle de toutes ces données là ? Vous
avez compris la question ?
Non, je vais être je suis pas
Oui, mais elle est horet
elle est hors sujet. On la prendra plus
tard. Celouton
le juge a été séparé pu considérer tu as
cette atteinte à la séparation des
pouvoirs. Ça veut dire aussi qu'il y a
pas de contradictoire. C'est sil décide
si le service spécialisé de de la police
décide que le site de Syerview fait
l'apologie du terrorisme parce que vous
avez interviewé Guillaume Muris qui est
quand même un végétarien notoire euh
et islamogauchiste.
Ah oui oui, au moins au moins.
[grognement] Euh donc vous êtes un site
terroriste, c'est évident. Donc plaf
bloqué.
En passant pas par un juge, ça veut dire
que vous avez pas été convoqué, vous
avez pas été prévenu, vous avez pas pu
présenter de défense, vous avez pas pu
vous justifier, euh vous avez pas pu
dire "Ah non, effectivement, telle
vidéo". Ouais, ouais, effectivement,
celle-là, elle va trop loin, on la
retire. En fait, on t'a pas permis de te
justifier.
Et le et le dééférencement, ça empêche
tout ça ? C'estd que c'est légal.
Ah, c'est Non, non, ça pose les mêmes
problèmes. Dans les décrets qu'on
attaquait, il y a le 2015 1225 qui est
celui sur le blocage et il y a le 2015
253 qui est celui sur le déférencement.
C'est exactement le même jeu. Donc non.
C'est c'est les mêmes questions. C'est
une forme de censure qui passe pas par
un juge.
Alexis, est-ce que vous pensez que les
les exégettes sont suffisamment
dimensionnés pour pouvoir s'opposer à
l'État quand l'État prend ce genre de
largesse ?
Honnêtement, non.
Clairement non. Euh on enfin on a un
petit groupe de un petit collectif qui
on essaie de faire beaucoup de choses.
On essaie de de lutter contre toutes les
comment dire enfin tous les toutes les
atteintes à l'état de droit que sur
lesquelles on pour lesquels on est
particulièrement sensible.
Vous êtes un peu des lanceurs d'alerte
non ? Alors, l'enceur d'alerte, c'est
peut-être pas, il y a peut-être un peu
de ça en ce queon essaie effectivement
de de mobiliser autour de ces questions.
Après, c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on fait
et nous, ce qu'on fait, on est plutôt on
essaie d'être des vies et dès qu'on voit
des des textes qui passent, qu'on
considère qu'il ne sont pas
conformes à la conception qu'on se fait
de l'état de droit, de la démocratie, de
la République, des garanties, des
libertés fondamentales, à ce moment-là,
on décide si on a un peu de temps, un
peu d'énergie, un peu de force à de
d'aller l'attaquer. Mais c'est pas
enfin, on est, il faut bien comprendre,
on est un tout petit groupe. Est-ce que
vous avez cherché à contacter par
exemple le Conseil national de la
magistrature ou euh le syndicat des
avocats ou euh
alors
le conseil de l'ordre des avocats ou des
choses comme ça ?
Euh bon, l'ordre des avocats se mobilise
sur euh certains sujets communs ou n
autres. Par exemple, ils ont attaqué la
loi renseignement devant la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme que
nous on avait attaqué en France. Don on
a attaqué l'ensemble des décrets
d'application devant le conseil d'État.
On a également fait plusieurs questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité
devant le Conseil constitutionnel. C'est
deux juridictions françaises. Donc nous
on attaqué ça en France. Eux l'ont
attaqué devant la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme. Donc on a on a des
sujets communs avec eux. En revanche, il
a des c'est pas le
comment dire la mission de l'ordre des
avocats d'attaquer ça. L'ord des
avocats, c'est un ordre professionnel
qui est là pour organiser une
profession. Il se trouve que là leur
renseignement on considérait que ça
portait atteinte à certaines garanties
de la profession. Donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont décidé de se mobiliser. Mais
ils n'ont pas vocation à se mobiliser
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets-là.
Euh pareil malheureusement pour le
syndicat des avocats de France et même
si on on est on est sur certains il y a
certains de nos affaires sur lesquelles
on on est en on est avec eux enfin on
attaque ensemble
mais ça reste marginal ce Laurence F à
ma connaissance on est les seuls à
l'avoir attaqué
on est les seuls à l'avoir trouvé drôle
mais il est vraiment drôle je pense que
c'est ça en fait les les faut repéré
c'est pas un dossier très stratégique
mais c'est un dossier que je trouve
trouve très symbolique parce que
l'affaire est simple, l'affaire est
bordée, il y a un point précis sur
lequel le Conseil d'État nous a dit "Ça
n'aura pas lieu parce que c'est pas
prévu par le décret." Nous, on pensait
que c'était du foutage de gueule. C'est
du foutage de gueule, ça se voit. Et ce
qui m'intéresse, c'est pas tellement
qu'on gagne, c'est que je pense que le
Conseil d'État va défendre le
gouvernement et je suis curieux de
savoir comment il va l'écrire. Avant
qu'on attaque le le
Je voulais compléter sur ta question
précédente de deux détails. Faut
comprendre que les exégettes, c'est pas
un groupe isolé. On s'inscrit dans des
collectifs. Typiquement les exégètes,
c'est une association de fête donc qui
ne peut pas signer qui peut pas est en
justice comme on dit. On peut pas
attaquer nous. Donc ce sont toujours
d'autres associations dont sont issus
les bénévoles qui sont là au départ.
FDN.
Alors ça va être FDN, ça va être la
Fédération FDN, ça va être la quadrature
du net, ça va être iguan.net. net. Ça va
être euh
des particuliers aussi, ça va être en
fait des associations qui ont un intérêt
à agir dans ce cas-là et avec lesquels
on bosse. Et ces associations
elles-mêmes s'inscrivent dans des
réseaux. Tu vois la Fédération FDN, il y
a 30 membres à peu près. Il y en a dans
toute la France, un en Belgique et un à
Saint-Bart si Marbon pour igen. Enfin,
tu vois, c'est vaste, c'est beaucoup
d'associations, donc qui veillent à
beaucoup de sujets. La quadrature est
évidemment en contact avec des dizaines
d'associations via différents collectifs
et cetera et cetera. L'observatoire des
libertés numériques par exemple où la
quadrature bosse beaucoup, on est en
contact avec pas mal de structures par
là. Comment elles vont les libertés en
ce moment sur internet ?
Mal pas que sur internet.
Alexis, ouais, on est dans une période
qui est enfin c'est c'est une question
qui est compliquée, mais on observe
quand même depuis un certain nombre
d'années qu'il y a un certain nombre de
changements. Il y a des bon ça fait 25
ans qu'il y a de plus en plus de de lois
antiterroristes qui qui sont prises et
qui petit à petit rognent quelque part
un petit peu certains certaines libertés
qu'on avait. Alors bien évidemment qu'il
faut également que les forces de police
aient les outils nécessaires pour
assurer la protection de la population.
Ça c'est évident. Mais en revanche,
ensuite, la question se pose de savoir
dans quelles conditions, comment,
quelles sont les garanties, quels sont
les recours euh et comment est-ce qu'on
fait en sorte que ça ne dégénère pas, où
est-ce qu'on met le curseur ? Et
effectivement aujourd'hui alors on n
plus dans le dans l'état d'urgence
l'état l'état d'urgence qui a duré quand
même 2 ans. Mais quelque part une grande
partie des des principes qui avaient été
enfin qui étaient mis en place dans
l'état d'urgence
sont maintenant dans l'état de droit
classique.
Euh donc bon, ça c'est peut-être une
première observation. La deuxième, c'est
que on il y a un certain nombre de de
d'auteurs, hein, c'est pas c'est pas du
tout
moi qui le dit, mais je je partage ce
constat. un certain nombre d'auteurs
notamment des même dans la doctrine
juridique classique hein, des profs de
droit, des avocats, ce genre de choses
qui observent qu' a il se passe un
certain glissement euh de la présomption
d'innocence qui est quand même un
principe fondamental dans notre droit
qui est protégé par notre code par nos
codes, par nos textes, mais également au
niveau européen et au niveau
international.
un certain glissement donc de la
présomption d'innocence vers une sorte
de suspicion de dangerosité
où vous êtes privé de certaines libertés
et de certains droits lorsque vous êtes
soupçonné être dangereux.
Comment tuexpliques ça ?
Je c'est difficile. C'est difficile à
expliquer.
C'est dû à une tension économique, une
tension sociale latente. C'est dû à quoi
?
Je pense que c'est un ensemble. Euh
tension économique, oui, par certains
côtés car parce que
les enfin le fait de mettre en en place
les moyens adéquat pour la police pour
agir pour assurer la protection de la
population, tout ça c'est des choses qui
coûtent cher. Et donc si en plus on met
des contraintes derrière pour assurer la
la sauvegarde des libertés fondamentales
et des droits fondamentaux, ça coûte
encore plus cher parce que il faut
mettre des mécanismes qui sont coûteux.
Il y a des délais à respecter et ça
demande l'intervention de plusieurs
personnes. C'est c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué.
Je pense qu'effectivement ça ça
s'explique par ça. Ça s'explique
également peut-être par au niveau au
niveau social
un
certaines évolutions qui sont marquées.
Le le fait que la population comprend de
moins en moins aujourd'hui pourquoi
est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir une sécurité
absolue, pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut pas
se quelque part réclamer et obtenir une
sécurité totalement absolue. Euh je
pense que ça ça passe par ça et ça passe
également par le fait que les un certain
nombre de de personnes politiques euh
lesquel
je ne citera pas de nom mais beaucoup en
réalité de tout bord confondu. Euh il
faut pas oublier que le l'état d'urgence
qu'on a connu qui a duré quand même très
très longtemps
le le le pansement sur la jambe de bois
voilà le dernier qu'on a connu c'était
la la gauche qui était au pouvoir
c'était pas la droite. Il faut il faut
je pense qu'il faut abandonner l'idée
que
que la gauche est socialiste.
Non, c'est pas ça. Mais il faut
abandonner l'idée qu'il n'y a que la
droite qui cherche à mettre des des
textes liberticides. Ça c'est ce n'est
pas vrai. On l'a vu le renseignement ça
a été voté. C'était la gauche qui était
au pouvoir.
Il y avait Axel le maire comme
secrétaire d'État. Oui, quand on on peut
même après argumenter sur le fait que le
la branche du PS qui était au pouvoir
n'était pas vraiment la gauche. Mais
c'est même pas le problème. Quand tu
regardes sur le sur l'Assemblée
nationale sur 577 députés, combien ont
voté contre l'état d'urgence
déjà ? Combien étaient là ? [grognement]
Oh, tous tous. Du vote solennel sur un
texte comme ça, il viennent tous. Il y
en a six qui ont voté contre. Six.
Lesquels ? Ah moi j'ai en tête Isabelle
et Sergio Coronado parce que c'est les
deux que je connais mais je sais qu'il y
en a six en tout.
Le le premier vote, ils sont six contre.
571 ont soit rien dit, soit voté pour
alors qu'il savait que c'était inutile.
Euh [grognement] si tu veux les les
après tu as les tu as les frappes à
dingue.
Enfin, je sais pas, Jacques Millard, il
est il est barré quoi. Euh
je te laisse responsable de cette
déclaration
mais
le enfin c'est le mec qui voulait
nationaliser internet si tu veux. C'est
tu vois Non mais il y a du lourd. Euh
avec ses petites mains.
Ouais. Ouais. Comme un grand. Et donc le
si tu veux les sur les 577, il y en a
570 qui votent pour euh donc ça va euh
de de l'aile droite de de LR jusqu'au PC
et aux partis de gauche, tu vois. Il y a
et les quelques qui se sont opposés,
alors 6 la première fois, ils étaient un
petit peu plus les fois d'après euh sur
les différents renouvellements,
mais ils sont répartis un peu dans tous
les camps. C'est juste les gens qui ont
qui ont un peu la tête froide et qui
font "Non, mais on vote n'importe quoi.
On est en train de voter n'importe quoi.
On vote ça, ça sert à rien. Ça coûte une
blinde, ça fonctionne pas. Ça épuise la
police,
ça fait du mal à nos libertés. Tu vois
les les interdictions de manifester
pendant qu'on pendant que se faisait la
contestation de de la loi travail, la
loi commerie, c'est n'importe quoi. Les
interdiction de manifester
les interdictions de manifester pendant
la COP 21
je dire parce que c'est bien connu en
France les attentats c'est toujours des
écolos. C'est le terrorisme en France
c'est un terrorisme d'écologiste. C'est
bien connu.
Mais on on utilise le l'état d'urgence
pour emmerder les écolos pendant la COP
21. En revanche, pendant que ils
viennent jouer à la babale, pendant
c'était la coupe d'Europe, je crois, euh
là non, autorisation de se de se de
manifester, de se rassembler, de de
faire la fête au stade et cetera. Donc
en fait pour la contestation politique,
on utilise l'état d'urgence et
l'antiterrorisme. Et pour les
rassemblements sportifs, ça c'est plus
important, on l'autorise quand même
pendant l'état d'urgence. C'est quand
même vachement intéressant. Ça dit des
choses sur l'état de la société. Ça veut
dire que le droit à une expression
politique et à la contestation politique
euh n'est plus reconnu.
Et c'est alors c'est pour le pour le
coup quand tu fais se trouve que ces
temps-ci je m'amuse à faire écouter un
peu d'anthropologie politique mais en
fait quand tu quand tu supprimes cette
chaîne de contestation politique et
quand il y a plus de négociation
possible c'estd que on peut manifester
ça ne change rien. Les manifestations
peuvent être pacifiques ou violentes, ça
ne change rien. Ça veut dire que la
décision du pouvoir politique n'est plus
négociable. Et si la décision du pouvoir
politique n'est plus négociable, c'est
qu'il y a plus de politique. Tuas un
auteur à nous conseiller en
anthropologie politique ? [grognement]
Alors, apparemment, le texte de
référence, c'est un livre qui s'appelle
Anthropologie politique de George
Balandier. Mais comme moi, je suis un
branleur et que je l'ai pas encore lu,
ce que je fais, c'est que je vais sur la
chaîne YouTube d'Alexandre Ducllot et
que je regarde ces différentes séries de
cours qui sont les cours qui donnent à
Tolbiac. Et c'est hyper instructif. Il y
a toute une série de 12 ou 13 cours sur
l'ordolibéralisme par exemple qui sont
hyper intéressantes.
Il y a toute une série de 2016 sur
solidarité et violence qui est
extrêmement intéressante.
Avant qu'on aborde le Privacy Shield,
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on aborde un
sujet ? Vous voulez Alexis, lance-nous
un sujet.
Euh,
tu peux te faire aider de ton petit
voisin de gauche, hein.
C'est un sujet en tête.
On a on a t les deux. C'est moins
compliqué que le progressive shield.
Ah, c'est intéressant ça. Ouais. Euh
ouais, pourquoi pas ? Tu veux qu'on
Alors, en fait les deux c'est un
faut remonter à quand même.
Ouais. Ah oui,
alors il se trouve que
dans le dans cette ambiance un petit peu
tendue au niveau des libertés
fondamentales et notamment des libertés
numériques, il y a quand même eu un
certains certaines vagues assez
positives qui venaient notamment de
l'Europe, notamment de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne.
Ça a commencé
enfin on peut prendre je pense comme
point de départ 2014 avril 2014 où la
cour de justice rend un arrêt DRI qui
était particulièrement
attendu et important parce que elle
annule euh la directive qui encadrait je
te souviens le nom exact de la directive
je
c'est la directive privacy de 2006 alors
le 2006 24 son numéro mais je suis pas
Euh en fait c'est la directive qui qui
encadre tout ce qui est rétention des
données de connexion.
Tu as le droit de reprendre la parole si
je je chercher le nom mais
c'est la c'est la directive en en droit
européen qui dit euh les Étatsmembres
devront faire des lois qui protègent la
correspondance privée et la vie privée
des gens et ne pourront collecter des
données que dans tel cadre. Ils devront
y accéder selon telle procédure et il
devrait y avoir telle garantie. On peut
pas conserver ces données plus de 2 ans
et cetera et cetera. Et
c'est une directive contre laquelle on
s'était pas mal battu à l'époque quand
elle a été prise en 2006
parce que c'est une directive qui
suppose qu'on va conserver des traces
sur tout le monde dans le doute
comme ça s'il s'avère que tu es un
délinquent, on pourra récupérer ce que
tu as fait il y a 3 mois ou il y a un
an.
C'est beau,
c'est beau. On surveille tout le monde
parce que tout le monde est suspect. Et
ça la CJI nous dit en 2014 dans l'arrêt
Digital Rland qu'il y a pas moyen. C'est
pas possible.
Ils ont conservé ce qu'ils avaient
stocké ou pas du tout ?
S'ils ont intercepté quelque chose
qui ont conservé. Ah le qui ça ?
Bah les
Non non. Alors parce que la directive
[grognement] a été annulée mais les lois
au niveau de enfin par exemple en France
ça n'a pas eu d'incidence. la les la
législation française et la
réglementation française qui organise
cette conservation généralisée des
données, elle est toujours justement et
c'est un de nos dossiers,
c'est une des choses qu'on attaque
devant le Conseil d'État. Euh elle est
toujours aujourd'hui, elle est c'est
toujours en cours, ça n'a absolument pas
changé. Donc ça ça a été la première
étape et suite à cela euh effectivement
bah donc du coup on a on a décidé de
d'attaquer ce euh cette réglementation
au niveau français en en considérant que
les la réglementation française n'était
pas conforme au droits de l'Union
européenne et il y a un principe de
primuté du droit à l'Union européenne
sur le droit français. Donc normalement
le droit européen est censé primer parce
que dans son arrêt Cour de justice
considérait que parce que la directive
prévoyait de mémoire une possibilité de
conserver les données entre 6 mois et 2
ans. Et après c'était à l'appréciation
de chaque état membre de mettre soit 6
mois, soit 8 mois, soit 2 ans, soit 1
an, soit un an et demi, peu importe
entre ce dans ce délai là. Euh et donc
la la cour de justice a donné un certain
nombre de d'éléments dans son arrêt
notamment un des éléments mis en place,
c'était celui que euh cette conservation
durait entre 6 mois et 2 ans de manière
totalement sans critère, de manière
totalement fou sur l'ensemble des
données. et bien ce n'était pas conforme
au droits de l'Union européenne,
aux droits fondamentaux de l'Union
européenne parce que la la
directive c'est ce qu'on appelle un acte
de droit dérivé et il y a d'autres actes
européens les traités fondamentaux et
notamment la charte des droits
fondamentaux qui sont censés être
supérieurs qui qui
priment également sur non sur le droit
dérivé. Donc ça veut dire que la
directive doit être conforme au traité.
Et ce qu'a fait la la la Cour de
justice, c'est qu'elle a annulé cette
directive en considérant que les cette
directive n'était pas conforme aux
droits dans les traités. D'accord ? Donc
il y a une question de il y a des droits
qui sont supérieurs à d'autres. Et nous,
on a attaqué donc le le régime français
devant le Conseil d'État. L'affaire est
toujours en cours. Ça va faire
maintenant
ben plus de 2 ans et demi à peu près 2
ans et demi que le dossier est en cours.
Euh et donc ce qu'on a mis enfin une des
choses qu'on a mis en avant c'était donc
bien sûr cette jurispondance.
Il se trouve que 1 an et demi après,
alors que notre affaire était en cours,
notre affaire était toujours en cours.
Donc avait on a eu un des échange avec
le gouvernement, un débat assez précis
sur l'interprétation de l'arrêt des RI
et notamment le le champ d'application
de l'Union européenne, savoir si
s'appliquait ou pas parce qu'il y a
aussi cette question de d'application.
Le 21 décembre 2016, la Cour de justice
rend à nouveau un arrêt qui est l'arrêt
Té2 qu'elle a rendu en grande chambre.
Alors, c'est pas un Odin, un grande
chambre, c'est c'est la formation la
plus sonnelle. La cour a plusieurs types
de formations et en fonction de
l'importance de l'affaire et de la la
comment dire la force qu'elle souhaite
donner à l'arrêt qu'elle va rendre, elle
le rend dans une formation plus ou moins
grande. Et donc T2, ça a été rendu dans
la formation la plus solannelle.
Et donc T2 vient dire deux choses. Alors
l'arrêt est assez long et assez enfin
motivé de manière assez précise mais en
résumant il y a deux points importants.
Il y a un point sur le la collecte des
données et un point sur l'accès aux
données collectées. Le point sur la
collecte des données.
T2 considère que euh une législation
régime d'un étatmembre, une
réglementation mise en place au niveau
de l'Étatmembre de l'Union européenne,
donc français par exemple qui euh
prévoirait la collecte et la
conservation généralisée de l'ensemble
des données
pour notamment des objectifs de lutte
contre la criminalité
n'est pas conforme à au droits de
l'Union européenne et notamment à
certaines dispositions de la charte des
droit fondamentaux. Ça c'est le premier
point. Et le deuxième point,
c'est ce qui concerne l'accès des
autorités étatiques à ces données. Et il
vient dire que un accès normalement euh
doit être limité à la lutte contre la
criminalité grave et pas n'importe quel
délit et infraction. C'est uniquement la
lutte contre la criminalité grave. Alors
après va se poser la question de savoir
qu'est-ce que c'est que la lutte contre
la criminalité grave. Mais on peut
supposer par exemple qu'un un une
consommation de stupéfiant ou un vol de
voiture, ça n'est pas de la lutte contre
la criminalité grave. La criminalité
grave, ça renvoie à des à des crimes
particulièrement
de sang, des crimes de sang
au moins et des choses même dans les
crimes de sang, des choses quand même
particulièrement graves et
particulièrement fiscal parre.
Je pense pas qu'on puisse considérer que
ça soit de la lutte contre la
criminalité grave sous réserve de ce qui
sera bien sûr jugé par par la la cour
éventuellement. Mais donc que cet accès
doit être limité à la lutte contre la
criminalité grave et qu'il doit y avoir
un certain nombre de garanties. Euh il
faut qu'il y ait notamment une
possibilité donc un contrôle par une
autorité administrative indépendante
préalable ou un contrôle par un juge.
Voilà ce genre de de garantie. Et donc
cet arrêt est venu en plein dans au
milieu de donc de notre affaire. Donc on
a signalé, on a fait on a pris des
nouvelles écritures euh pour dire bon
ben voilà, ça confirme notre
interprétation du droit, ça vient
confirmer ce qu'on disait. Euh et bon
pour l'instant le conseil d'État ne
s'est pas prononcé. On espère qu'il se
prononcera rapidement.
De donner des dates.
[raclement de gorge]
Le le texte dans lequel nous on fait
l'analyse de l'arrêt Télé2 et qu'on
transmet au Conseil d'État en disant
regardez c'est conforme à ce qu'on a
dit. Euh il est de février 2017 donc il
y a plus d'un an et il y a pas la
procédure n'a pas bougé depuis il y a
pas eu de réponse de personne. En
revanche mais je suis venu avec des
écrits parce que tu m'as dit de venir
avec des écrits. Alors je précise je
cite mes sources. Donc ça c'est tiré du
site du Conseil d'État. Ah oui, il faut
que j'explique parce que je pense que
les gens savent pas. Euh le
dis bonjour à la team 5h.
Ouais. Le il y a de deux trucs que
j'explique avant de faire mon petit bout
de lecture. Ce que c'est que le Conseil
d'État.
On les gens connaissent un petit peu le
droit pénal où tu as fait des bêtises,
tu vas
te faire juger alors au tribunal
correctionnel, à la cour d'assise et
cetera. Puis si tu estimes que le
jugement est pas bon, tu fais appel.
Et puis si en appel tu peux plus
contester le fond de l'affaire, mais si
tu estimes que le droit a été mal
appliqué, c'est en
cassation,
tu estimes que le juge a pas compris
l'article de loi qu'il était en train
d'appliquer, tu peux aller en cassation
et la cour de cassation
dira tel article de loi, il se lit comme
ça et donc bah le juge avait raison ou
le juge s'est gourré et on recommence
bien en droit administratif,
c'est-à-dire en fait quand tu attaques
non pas un particulier mais que tu
attaques l'administration donc l'État à
quand tu veux contester un permis de
construire par exemple,
tu quand tu attaques une une décision de
l'administration, tu l'attaques au
tribunal administratif. Si tu es pas
content, tu vas en cours administratif
d'appel. Si tu estimes que le droit a
était mal appliqué, l'équivalent de la
Cour de cassation, c'est la section du
contentieux du Conseil d'État.
Euh donc c'est la plus haute autorité
administrative en droit enfin judiciaire
juridique en droit administratif. Et il
faut comprendre alors ça après on joue
avec les titres en France c'est très
français. Le président du Conseil d'État
est structurellement le premier ministre
et il ne fait rien dans le Conseil
d'État. Il vient même pas aux réunions.
Il a juste le titre de président du
Conseil d'État. C'est décoratif.
C'est honorifique et c'est c'est
l'héritage en fait de le
c'est une petite prime à la fin du mois.
Non non non c'est c'est l'héritage en
réalité de de le du enfin des anciens
régimes qui a eu le Conseil d'État. Il
faut bien comprendre qu'en réalité ça
existe depuis Napoléon et même avant en
réalité c'était le conseil du roi
c'était voilà c'était le conseil royal
euh donc ça a pris sa ça ça a évolué
hein depuis Philippe Lebel on peut
remonter les formes anciennes de conseil
du roi ça a pris plusieurs formes et
ensuite ça Napoléon qui a créé un un
conseil d'état un peu tel qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui qui a énormément évolué à
travers les les régimes
et mais donc il faut bien comprendre
voilà que à l'époque le président du
Conseil d'État c'était l'empereur où
c'était éventuellement ensuite au fil
des régimes soit le président du conseil
soit le garde des sauts en fonction des
constitutions et cetera et aujourd'hui
formellement mais ça n'a aucune
incidence, il n'a aucune autorité
formelle sur le sur les les les
membres du du Conseil d'État. le le
président effectivement c'est le premier
ministre mais donc
le personnage intéressant c'est
effectivement c'est le vice-président
et enchaîn
donc le patron entre guillemets du
conseil d'état c'est le vice-président
et donc ça c'est une intervention de
Jean-Marc Sauvé vice-président du
Conseil d'État au congrès du 25e
anniversaire de l'Académie de droits
européen à Trève le 19 octobre 2017
publié sur le site du Conseil d'État
imprimé ce matin. Alors il a déjà sa
petite faussette donc ça veut dire que
ça va être croustillant.
Voilà voilà voilà. Donc la question est
la cour de justice continue alors la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
continue de rendre des décisions qui
divergent parfois de l'application des
autorités nationales. Je vous zappe une
ligne histoire de gagner un peu de
temps. Et donc là Jean-Marc Sauvé nous
dit c'est aussi le cas avec l'arrêt plus
récent T les deux vériges du 21 décembre
2016 qui a précisé dans un sens
restrictif la jurisprudence
résultant de l'arrêt digital rightland
de 2014 invalidant la directive de 2006
sur la conservation des données au motif
que la possibilité donnée aux États
membres d'imposer aux opérateurs de
communication de conserver l'ensemble
des données de connexion des
utilisateurs pour une durée maximale
comprise entre 6 mois et 2 ans. Mais
connaissait le droit au respect de la
vie privée des personnes et le droit à
la protection des données personnelles.
Cette décision, donc ça veut dire qu'il
a à peu près compris le texte quand
même. C'est plutôt [grognement] cette
décision pouvait faire l'objet de deux
interprétations.
Une interprétation souple selon laquelle
la collecte et la conservation
indifférenciée de données sont possibles
à condition d'être justifié par des
objectifs sérieux et d'être assortis de
garanties suffisantes.
une interprétation stricte conduisant à
écarter toute forme de collecte et de
conservation indifférenciée des données,
y compris pour des modèles d'intérêt
général. Dans son étude annuelle 2014,
puis en formation juridictionnelle, le
Conseil d'État avait pris position en
faveur de la première interprétation,
donc souple.
Par son arrêté télé vérig, la Cour de
justice n'a pas retenu cette analyse et
elle a considérablement réduit la marge
d'appréciation des États en ce qui
concerne la possibilité d'ordonner la
conservation des données de connexion, y
compris dans le cadre de la lutte contre
le terrorisme ou la criminalité
organisée. Donc en fait le patron du
Conseil d'État, il sait qu'on a raison,
il le dit
depuis février 2017, on attend leur
réponse.
Tu tu leur passes un petit message là
devant la caméra ? Tu veux qu'on donne
ton numéro de téléphone portable
directement pour qu'il te rappelle ? Il
déjà. Ils l'ont déjà.
Ils l'ont déjà.
Ils l'ont déjà. Il est sur les recours
puisque sur ce recours là, je crois bien
que c'est moi le mandataire unique.
On fait comment pour les sanctionner ces
gens-là quand ils font pas leur taf ?
Le Conseil d'État, on peut pas.
C'est un problème ? Non,
c'est le problème d'une cour suprême. Ça
c'est ça, si tu veux, ça peut faire une
très belle digression en dehors de nos
dossiers. C'est le problème d'une cour
suprême. Comment tu sanctionnes une Cour
suprême ?
Normalement, on la sanctionne pas et on
la sanctionne pas parce que les gens qui
sont là sont irréprochables.
Après, juste pour peut-être nuancer un
tout petit peu, c'est pas là aujourd'hui
on attend la réponse. Bon, ça fait un
c'est un petit peu long, mais c'est pas
non plus particulièrement long qu'on
enfin par rapport à au délai de la
justice en France. C'est c'est un délai
qui est relativement euh classique, même
si c'est vrai que là on commence quand
même à rentrer dans un déli un petit peu
long, mais ça veut pas forcément dire
qu'ils ne font pas leur travail. Ça veut
C'est quoi le budget du ministère de la
justice en France ?
Je connais pas honnêtement. Je j'ai
aucune idée. Je sais que il y a en ce
moment il y a des grves très fortes de
des avocats, des magistrats, des
grefiers par rapport au projet de loi
sur la la justice parce qu'il considère
que il y a des un point assez
structurant qui ne conviennent pas pour
une justice de qualité, une justice euh
moderne et mais en même temps qui
permettent justement de de rendre le
droit de manière sereine dans des dans
de bonnes conditions. Mais je j'ai pas
du tout le chiffre en tête. Je pourrais
je pourrais pas vous le dire. Je sais
simplement qu'il mériterait d'être
augmenté, ça c'est sûr. Et quand je dis
augmenté, c'est probablement doublé.
Mais je j'ai pas de du tout de chiffre à
vous donner.
Bon, on attaque le Privacy Shield.
Bah, tuas tu as un bout qui est
intéressant dans ce que je ce que je te
proposais comme digression, c'est la
notion de cours suprême.
En [raclement de gorge] France, il y a
trois euh potentielles cours suprême. Tu
as la Cour de cassation, tu as le
Conseil d'État et tu as le Conseil
constitutionnel.
Parce qu'en fait la Cour de cassation
peut pas juger si un texte est conforme
à la Constitution ou pas.
Le Conseil d'État peut juger si un
décret est conforme à la Constitution ou
si une loi est conforme au trait
européen.
Mais c'est le Conseil constitutionnel
qui dit si une loi est conforme à la
Constitution. tu un espèce de bidule à 3
et sur les trois, il y en a deux qui
sont bizarres
puisque le Conseil constitutionnel,
si tu regardes comment c'est constitué,
c'est pas des magistrats, c'est de
l'ancien ministre. Alors, il y a
quelques magistrats et quelques
professeurs de droit dans le lot qui
sont des des
Tous ces gens-là sont éminemment
respectables, mais enfin, c'est des
anciens ministres beaucoup, une petite
moitié si je me trompe pas.
[grognement]
Euh enfin, tu vois, Lionel Jospin, il
est pas professeur de droit
constitutionnel.
Euh, il est au Conseil constitutionnel.
Jean-Louis Debré qui en a été président
pendant 9 ans, je crois.
Euh c'est pas un professeur de droit
constitutionnel, c'est un ancien
ministre de l'intérieur.
C'est il a pas spécialement brillé par
son respect de la justice et sa
connaissance du droit. Il était ministre
de la police. C'est pas complètement
pareil, quoi.
C'est pas une planque dorée.
Je crois pas. Crois pas que si, mais ces
gens-là ont tous des planques dorées. Je
si tu veux quand tu es quand tu es à ce
niveau-là dans de l'état, tu la planque
dorée, tu en as tant que tu veux. Par
rapport à ce que je connais dans le
privé, c'est pas c'est pas significatif
quoi. Ça ça vaut pas un parachute doré
du CAC 40. Euh là où ça c'est plus
embêtant, c'est pas une vraie formation
de juristes. La Cour constitutionnelle
de Carls Rou, c'est des magistrats,
c'est des gens qui ont fait toute leur
carrière dans le droit.
[grognement]
Euh et puis le Conseil d'État, c'est
encore autre chose parce que tu as un
mélange, tu as trois sections dans le
Conseil d'État. Tu as la section du
rapport qui planche sur un rapport
annuel. Il se trouve qu'en 2014 euh
c'était sur le numérique et que du coup
ils ont décidé qu'ils étaient pas
d'accord avec la CJUE. Et en 2016, la
CJUE a répondu que c'est elle qui avait
raison. Euh,
il y a la section du conseil qui est en
fait tout le morceau du Conseil d'État
qui bosse avec les ministères. En fait,
il y en a plusieurs sections. Il y a
plusieurs sections administratives. Euh,
par exemple, il y a la section de
l'intérieur, la section des finances, la
section des travaux publics et et chaque
section rend des avis sur par exemple
sur les travaux publics, c'est tout ce
qui va concerner les les textes relatifs
aux constructions. La section de
l'intérieur, ça va être les textes
relatifs justement aux libertés. La
section des finances, ça va plutôt être
les textes relatifs aux finances
publiques. Il y a la section du rapport
et des études et il y a la section du
contentieux. Voilà quel la trè branche.
Donc en fait, il mélange un morceau qui
devrait être une cour complètement
isolée, indépendante de l'exécutif
avec euh en gros un vivier de
conseiller.
Et c'est très étrange. C'est très
étrange. Euh c'est pas commun dans les
cours suprêmes en Europe. Cette espèce
de mélange
parce
c'est alors ça c'est de l'historique,
c'est de la tradition. C'est on fait
comme ça depuis 1800 quelque chose.
[soupir]
Il se trouve que son conseiller d'État
les N premiers de chaque promo de l'énat
et que bah dans les N premiers de chaque
promo de l'ENAT, tu fabriques du
ministre ou tu fabriques du directeur de
cabinet et
voilà, c'est comme ça, c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne en France. Mais c'est
un peu étrange.
On fait le privacy Shield.
Alors le privacy Shield, qu'est-ce que
c'est ?
Ça tout commence également par un encore
un arrêt de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne. Cette fois-ci en
2015, fin 2015, l'automne 2015, la Cour
de justice rend un arrêt Max Schrems qui
est du nom de la personne qui avait du
juris qui avait porté le le contentieux
Max Schrems où elle annule euh elle
invalide le Safe Harbor.
Très important
le safe Harbor. Alors, il faut faut
revenir à la base. L'idée générale,
c'est que normalement l'ensemble des
données personnelles des Européens
doivent être lorsqu'il y a collecte et
traitement doit être traité et collecté
sur le territoire de l'Union européenne.
Il y a des dérogations possibles et une
de ces dérogations, c'est lorsque un
État présente des garanties équivalentes
aux garanties européennes. Et dans ces
cas-là, comment ça va ça fonctionne ?
Alors, il y a plusieurs procédures type,
mais une des procédures, c'est de passer
par la Commission européenne qui va
étudier le garanties de l'État, voir si
c'est équivalent, si le droit est
équivalent, si les régimes sont
équivalents, les procédures sont
équivalentes et notamment si les
garanties fondamentales sont respectées.
Et dans ces dans ces conditions, elle va
prendre une décision d'adéquation.
Cette décision d'adéquation, c'est une
décision par laquelle elle va considérer
que le droit est suffisamment adéquate
pour de tel état est suffisamment
adéquate. Et le sbor, c'était comme ça
qu'on appelait la décision d'adéquation
de la Commission européenne par rapport
aux États-Unis qui datait du début des
années 2000. Je crois que c'était 2002
si
j'ai plus
commencé à sucer les datas de tout le
monde.
Oui. Au
moment où internet explose,
l'informatique explose.
En fait, c'est au moment où la directive
septembre
privacy de 2002 est prise
qui est celle qui celle de 2006 qui a
été annulée par Digital Rland. Avant, il
y a une a tout un paquet de directive en
2002 qui en droit une fois transposé en
droit français deviennent la loi sur la
confiance en l'économie numérique.
Et
c'est cette directive là. euh qui
dit les il y a des protections pour les
données personnelles des Européens, il y
a euh il y a des garanties, ça doit pas
sortir du territoire ou alors il faut un
accord. Donc le Saf Harbor est pris à ce
moment-là, mais c'est c'est une
saloperie le Saf Harbor.
Le problème c'est que euh enfin la
question qui se posait qui était portée
par donc un Maxams à l'époque euh
c'était de savoir si les garanties
étaient effectivement suffisantes ou
pas. Et la Cour de justice invalide le
CFBOR parce qu'elle considère que ces
garanties sont pas du tout suffisantes,
que il y a pas de recours effectif, il y
a pas d'intervention d'une autorité
indépendante, il y a pas de enfin toutes
les garanties du droit de l'Union
européenne ne sont pas respectées. Donc
le SFBOR est annulé.
Bien entendu, ça ça fait quand même un
peu de remou à l'époque cette histoire
parce qu'on se demandait du coup comment
est-ce que le transfert des données
personnelles des citoyens européens
lorsqu'ils utilisent des services de
d'opérateurs américains, donc
c'est-à-dire la l'écrasante majorité des
opérateurs sur internet aujourd'hui euh
des acteurs tels que Amazon, Facebook,
Google, Microsoft et cetera. Comment
est-ce que ça allait fonctionner
légalement ? Parce qu'on était dans une
période un petit peu d'incertitude.
Et dès l'été 2016,
la commission prend une nouvelle
décision. d'adéquation en considérant
que euh il y a eu de nouvelles garanties
qui ont été apportées par les les
États-Unis. Il y a eu un échange, il y a
eu des voilà des discussions, des
négociations de billets.
Donc cette nouvelle décision qui
s'appelle le privacy Shield qu'on
appelle le privacy Shield.
Et le privacy field, nous on l'a on l'a
regardé
et on s'est dit en réalité que bon, il y
a eu des progrès par rapport au cbor
mais en réalité il y a tout autant de de
de scor qui reste encore à corriger.
Aujourd'hui, on considère que le privacy
field n'apporte absolument pas une
protection équivalente au droit de
l'Union européenne. Donc concrètement,
ça veut dire que lorsque nos données
personnelles sont traitées par des
opérateurs américains, on considère que
le le la protection qui sont apportées
par le droit européen n'est absolument
pas suivi, n'est absolument pas
équivalent.
Euh donc voilà comment ça a commencé.
Donc on a décidé d'attaquer
donc cette décision devant le tribunal
de l'Union européenne.
Euh aujourd'hui. Donc on a attaqué ça
fin 2016, la l'instance est en cours. On
soulève en gros quatre gros arguments.
Premier argument principal, c'est qu'on
considère que il n'y a pas de recours
effectif. Ça veut dire que lorsque
normalement lorsqu'il y a un un
traitement de données qui ne respecte
pas les conditions qui sont posées par
les par le droit, il doit pouvoir
d'avoir un recours effectif pour la
personne qui en est l'objet et elle doit
pouvoir demander à ce qu'il y a des
corrections qui soient faites que les
données soient corrigées ou
éventuellement si le le traitement est
complètement illégal qu'il soit
supprimé. Nous on considère que le droit
américain aujourd'hui n'offre pas aux
européens un recours effectif. Donc ça
c'est le premier argument qu'on met en
avant.
Le deuxième argument qu'on met en avant,
c'est de dire que il n'y a pas euh
d'intervention d'une autorité
indépendante dans le contrôle justement
de ces règles. Parce que encore qu'il y
ait des règles, c'est bien, mais encore
faut-il que sa règle soit appliquée.
Donc pour qu'elle soit appliquée, il
faut qu'on puisse les contrôler. Et
aujourd'hui, on considère que les les
acteurs qui rentrent, les acteurs
américains qui rentrent en en dans en
ligne de de cause dans ce dans ce
contrôle ne sont absolument pas euh une
autorité indépendante.
Euh 3è
3è argument qu'on met en place, c'est de
dire que il n'y a pas de euh
il y a une collecte des données qui est
généralisée. Tout à l'heure, on a dit
justement que Télé2 interdisait la
collecte généralisée des données. Et
bien le droit américain aujourd'hui en
ce qui concerne nos données des nous
citoyens européens les collègues de
manière généralisée. Nous c'est ce qu'
c'est ce qu'on considère. Et 4rième
argument, on considère que l'accès
à ces données n'est pas diff n'est pas
différencié. Donc ça veut dire que il
n'est pas limité à ce qui est
strictement nécessaire. Tout à l'heure,
on a vu également que Télé2, s'agissant
de l'accès aux données, limité cet accès
sous certaines conditions assez
substantielles à la lutte contre la
criminalité grave. Et bien aux
États-Unis, ça n'est pas le cas. Donc ça
c'est en gros la structure de notre
argumentation c'est ça c'est ça qu'on
met en avant
et et le gouvernement français il vous
aide il vous aide pas
et maintenant il il nous aide pas et pas
du tout parce qu'en réalité donc on
attaque cette décision de la Commission
européenne et il se trouve que contre
nous on a la Commission européenne mais
on a également un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui ont décidé d'intervenir au
soutien de la Commission européenne.
Des acteurs privés
des États et des acteurs privés certains
acteurs privés.
le gouvernement français intervient
contre nous.
Mais ça ça c'est super intéressant
politiquement.
C'est super intéressant politiquement
parce que si tu regardes tout ce qui
s'est raconté euh je suis désolé, je
vais élargir un tout petit peu mais
quand
quand la FCC a cassé ses textes sur la
neutralité du dire
c'est le régulateur des télécom
américains qui a cassé les textes qui
protégeaient la neutralité du net aux
États-Unis. On va y venir. Continue.
Euh quand il y a l'affaire en cours là
dont tout le monde parle, Facebook et
Cambridge Analytica,
euh écoute ce que racontent les acteurs
européens, les commissaires européens et
les ministres français. Ils t'expliquent
tous le droit européen est très
protecteur.
Le le règlement général sur la
protection des données personnelles, le
la loi,
le règlement européen sur la neutralité
du net. Enfin, tous ces textesl sont
très protecteurs, ce qui est
relativement vrai. Mais à côté de ces
textes super protecteurs, il y a le
privacy Shield qui dit "Pour Facebook,
c'est open bar et ils appliqueront le
droit américain." Donc en fait, le droit
européen, il est très protecteur mais il
ne contraint il ne contraint pas
Facebook. C'est ça que dit le Privacy
Shield,
Facebook, Apple,
Facebook, Apple, enfin toutes les boîtes
américaines qui veulent faire commerce
en Europe et qui se sont déclaré
conformes parce qu'en fait, il suffit de
se déclarer conforme pour que hop, c'est
bon, sans contrôle.
C'est ça le privacy shield.
Et donc en ce moment, tout le gratin
politique vient expliquer que ah là le
droit européen qu'est-ce qu'il est beau,
qu'est-ce qu'il est protecteur. Et en
même temps, ils sont contre nous pour
défendre le privacy shield en expliquant
que le droit américain est bien
suffisant. Parce que c'est ça qu'ils
expliquent en défense. Ils expliquent le
droit américain est bien suffisant en
terme de protection des données
personnelles, c'est-à-dire exactement le
contraire de ce qu'il raconte face
caméra
comme d'habitude.
Bah c'est que ça fait quand même rigolo
quand tu le vois
ou quand tu es au courant.
Bah quand tu es au courant c'est une
chose, tu soupçonnes, tu suputes et puis
tu te dis non mais je suis un
complotiste,
je suis encore avec les mecs de
Syerview.
Il y a Jean-Michel Complot, il va
m'embarquer. Bon [grognement]
mais quand tu entends enf je sais pas
quand quand j'étais au vœux de l'Arceep
le régulateur français des télécom veut
annuel en janvier Pierre Moskovici était
là le commissaire européen français
était là alors bon on écoute
religieusement son discours en attendant
le champagne [grognement]
et les petits fours
et oui les petits fours étaient super
bon euh
et le mec t'explique que en Europe il y
avait une unanimité pour défendre la
neutralité du net mais de Quelle hauteur
de foutage de gueule on parle. On s'est
battu pied à pied contre son
gouvernement, virgule par virgule. Et je
me souviens très bien que dans le
gouvernement précédent, c'est Axel le
maire qui a réussi à basculer la
position de la France. Mais pendant des
années, la France Bery
[raclement de gorge]
avec Orange à la manœuvre derrière euh
se battait pied à pied contre la
neutralité du net en Europe.
On embrasse Axel au passage
et donc il a fallu qu'on leur fasse la
guerre à ces gens-là pour réussir à
sauver les meubles en matière de
neutralité du net. Parce que le texte
qui est sorti est relativement faible
par rapport à ce qui était sorti du
Parlement européen.
Si tu veux entendre Moscovici venir
raconter que en Europe il y a unanimité,
il nous joue de la il nous joue de la
flû et ils nous font la même sur les
données personnelles en ce moment.
Pourquoi il alors je vais faire mon
Benet hein ? Pourquoi ils veulent
attaquer la neutralité du nette un peu
partout ? Pourquoi aux États-Unis
question d'internet, la loi votée aux
États-Unis sur la neutralité du net-elle
nous affecter sur nos libertés ? Il y a
il y a énormément de questions qui
traînent autour de la neutralité du net
en ce moment et bien avant pourquoi ils
veulent un être pas neutre ? Alors faut
comprendre qui veut dans l'histoire.
Alors il y a les fournisseurs de câbles
et il y a ceux qui utilisent les câbles.
Alors il y a les Ouais. Il y a les les
opérateurs, il y a les fournisseurs de
contenu et il y a les politiques.
Euh les politiques en général, ils
cherchent à favoriser le business et
donc ils sont assez d'accord avec le
grand groupe de leur pays.
Orange.
En [grognement] France, le grand groupe,
c'est Orange, c'est pas Google. Donc on
est plutôt d'accord avec Orange.
C'est pour c'est ça la position
historique de la France et c'est ce
point là que Axel le maire a réussi à
faire basculer. Euh je quand elle me l'a
dit quand je me souviens, on était toi
et moi dans son bureau, [grognement]
on venait de faire une interview et
c'était une rencontre off.
C'était une rencontre off celle-là et
qu'elle nous en a parlé. Euh
c'est pas grave mais elle nous en a
parlé. Elle nous a dit "Je vais réussir,
j'espère réussir." Je la croyais pas. Et
voilà. Donc du coup depuis je salue le
fait qu'elle a réussi.
Euh
et donc le
l'élément clé là-dedans, c'est pourquoi
les opérateurs veulent pas de neutralité
du net. En général, c'est une vision à
courte vue. Euh ce qu'ils espèrent,
c'est dire si toi abonné tu veux
regarder Netflix, ça va consommer
beaucoup de bandes passantes. Donc je
vais demander à Netflix de me reverser
10 % de ce qui de ce que tu payes
d'abonnement.
Et ça fait des pépettes en plus. Alors
ça c'est une bon, je trouve que c'est
stratégiquement une bêtise mais euh
c'est c'est ça la position des
opérateurs. Et en fait quand tu quand tu
dépiotes tout, au bout du bout ce que
les opérateurs espèrent gagner avec ça,
c'est quelques millions ou quelques
dizaines de millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires à à hauteur d'orange. Orange,
c'est c'est en milliards d'euros. C'est
8 ou 9 milliards d'euros sur le Orange
grand public en France. Quelques
millions, on s'en fout.
C'est c'est même pas 1 % du chiffre
d'affaires. C'est rien. C'est rien du
tout. C'est des clopinettes.
Je me souviens dans le dans le débat
précédent
au tout début du mandat de François
Hollande sur la neutralité du net,
j'avais j'avais poussé euh Orange dans
ses retranchements.
J'avais suggéré à des conseillers de
ministres un argument vachement rigolo
qui était de dire "OK, dites à Orange,
on vous fout la paix sur la neutralité
du net, on vous fout la paix, open bar,
ce sera comme vous voulez.
On protège rien, il y a pas de
neutralité du net. C'est comme vous
voulez, tranquille. En échange, vous
vous engagez à fibrer la France sans
investissement public.
Quand il y a eu le colloque organisé par
Bercy sur le sujet, le mec de la
Fédération française des Télécom, donc
qui représente tous les gros opérateurs
parlait juste avant moi qui moi
représente la Fédération des
fournisseurs d'accès internet
associatif.
Tu as les géants et les nains. C'était
très rigolo. Et juste avant moi, il
prend c'est lui qui c'est son tour de
parler et il explique que
il a entendu parler du fait qu'il y
avait des histoires sur les
investissements de la fibre. On parle
pas des mêmes ordres de grandeur. Ça
c'est en million, l'autre c'est en
milliard, ça n'a rien à voir. Il y a un
facteur 1000, on n'est pas du tout sur
les mêmes sommes. Donc il termine son
petit laus et puis moi je commence le
mien par écoutez mon mon prédécesseur
vient d'expliquer que il était en train
de se battre pour de l'argent de poche.
Du coup je propose qu'on arrête
et si tu veux c'est ça le le point clé.
Et en fait aux États-Unis le faut
comprendre que la situation est très
différente. Il y a beaucoup de réseaux
sur lesquels il y a pas eu
d'investissement où le réseau ADSL est
de mauvaise qualité où il est non
concurrentiel.
Dans [raclement de gorge] une ville aux
États-Unis, tu as en standard deux
opérateurs. Tu as l'opérateur qui
détient le réseau câblé qui n'a pas de
concurrent et tu as l'opérateur qui
détient le réseau ADSL qui est
l'opérateur historique de la ville et
qui n'a pas de concurrent. Et donc les
réseaux étant de relativement mauvaise
qualité, il y a pas d'investissement qui
sont faits dessus. Les abonnements
restent très chers qu'il ressemblent
beaucoup à ce qu'on connaissait comme
abonnement à internet au milieu des
années 90 en France.
Genre 56k qui ram.
Ouais. Enfin pour te donner une idée, un
accès câble un peu correct aux
États-Unis 100 dollars.
C'est stand pour de l'accès internet par
le câble.
C'est un T1, c'est ça ?
Bah non, ça va te donner ça va te donner
20 M.
Ouais. avec peut-être un ou de méga en
upload,
tu vois 100 dollars, c'estd que on parle
de 80 € tu vois c'est en France cet
accès là, il vaut 20 ou 25 € c'est pas
c'est pas les mêmes ordres de grandeur
et et en fait il y a tout un travail que
les opérateurs ont pas fait d'entretien
de leurs réseaux et cetera et alors du
coup ça fait qu'effectivement les
réseaux sont lents et donc pour faire
passer Netflix il faut le prioriser
sinon il marchera jamais. L'autre
solution serait de mettre le réseau aux
normes et de passer à la fibre optique
par exemple
mais ça ils le font pas. Donc en fait,
ils justifient l'absence de neutralité
du net par la vétusteté et le manque
d'investissement et le
sous-investissement dans leur réseau.
C'estàd leur incurie des 15 dernières
années, ils s'en servent comme argument
pour continuer à ne pas mettre un
niveau.
Ah c'est c'est un peu bizarre.
[grognement]
Les grands acteurs de contenu, les
Google et Netflix, eux ça les arrange
parce que si tu dis que pour avoir de la
bonne qualité, il faut payer
et ben toi qui est le gros acteur en
place qui est Google, Amazon, Netflix,
machin, tu peux mettre du pognon sur la
table parce que tu en as du pognon.
Le prochain qui va se monter, il a pas
les tunes. Donc en fait, tu garantis que
tu seras le seul. Tu garantis ton
monopole, c'est beau.
Tu garantis qu'il y aura pas de nouvel
entrant pour venir te faire chier.
Tu assures ton monopole.
Plus rigolo, tu regardes un tout petit
peu plus loin.
Mais en fait, s'il y a plus de
neutralité du net, euh très rapidement,
tu te retrouves avec un effet qui est
l'effet du Kindle. Je sais pas si tu
connais
petite liseuse.
La petite liseuse d'Amazon.
Quand tu achètes un Kindle, il y a un
accès réseau dedans.
Tu peux pas,
il y a un accès réseau qui permet de
télécharger le bouquin que tu viens
d'acheter sur sur Amazon avec ta
tablette Amazon que tu as payé avec ton
argent Amazon sur un ordinateur Amazon.
Enfin, tu on dirait Apple [grognement]
et c'est qui l'opérateur réseau de ce
trucl ? Et ben en fait, tu sais pas et
tu t'en fous. Toi, tu as acheté une
Kindle, tu sais même pas qu'il y a un
opérateur réseau. Je trouve qu'il y en a
un, sinon ça marcherait pas, ça pourrait
pas télécharger le bouquin. Euh mais tu
sais pas qui c'est, tu sais pas ce qu'il
fait, tu sais pas combien il est payé.
En fait, il existe plus.
il est devenu
sous-traitant
et en fait c'est ce qui va se passer
c'est ce qui risque de se passer s'il y
a pas de neutralité du net en fait les
gens ils vont pas acheter un accès
internet de telle ou telle marque et à
côté s'abonner à Netflix ils vont
acheter Netflix
ils vont acheter Googleet ils vont
acheter Appleet
Facebook net
ou Facebook net et qu'il y a derrière
ils s'en foutent
et du coup l'opérateur
disparaît. Il disparaît complètement.
C'est pas que Netflix va reverser 10 % à
Orange, pas du tout. c'est que Orange va
devenir un sous-traitant de Netflix
et Orange n'a plus de contact avec le
client, ne peut plus faire valoir ses
produits, ne peut plus négocier ses
propres marges, se retrouve 100 %
dépendant économique de deux ou trois
géants et ils sont morts.
Alexis,
j'ai ma Jamain a bien couvert le sujet.
En même temps, il est sur ses questions
depuis tellement longtemps que ça ne
m'étonne pas. Non, j'ai j'ai moi je
enfin je considère que la neutralité du
net, c'est quelque chose de vraiment
fondamental. On a la chance en Europe
d'avoir un régime qui est quand même
assez protecteur par rapport aux
États-Unis. Euh ce qu'il faut c'est se
battre pour que ça se maintienne et que
ça ça reste le cas. et surtout pas que
ça devienne comme aux États-Unis
euh justement quelque part un marché où
c'est uniquement la loi du plus fort qui
qui l'emporte et pas et pas et pas la
protection justement de de nos droits en
sachant que justement la la neutralité
des lunettes, ça renvoie également d'un
point de vue strictement juridique égal
à d'autres concepts que sont par exemple
la liberté d'expression le parce que
c'est ça le fait sur un réseau de
décider
quel paquet doit passer ou quel paquet
doit passer à quelle vitesse.
c'est qu'on on hiérarchise des contenus
qui sont plus ou moins importants.
Et derrière ça, c'est c'est une question
de liberté d'expression. C'est ça veut
dire que le le fournisseur d'accès dans
son réseau décide que telle personne a
une expression qui est plus importante
que telle autre ou que telle autre
personne c'est pas très grave si les p
c'est bien c'est bien pour organiser la
structure thing ça non ?
C'est-à-dire quelle structure
? Influencer les opinions sur internet.
Ah bah ça ça rejoint Oui, bien entendu.
Et donc on va faire une petite
transition parce que là vous venez de
nous assommer pendant 1 heure sur de la
réglementation et ainsi de suite.
C'est très soft, on est plus dur
d'habitude.
Ouais ouais. Bon maintenant, on va on va
on va commencer se réveiller un peu. On
n pas cité un seul article de loi. C'est
bon euh la campagne de Trump,
l'astroturfing
Google
Cambridge Analytica, ça vous fait penser
à quoi tout ça ? C'est ça pose enfin
c'est problématique et ça pose de
nombreux problèmes tant philosophique,
démocratique et juridique. Enfin c'est
c'est une affaire qui est assez assez
complexe.
C'est les Russes c'est pas les Russes.
Ça ça on verra. Il y a une enquête qui a
été ouverte.
D'après ce que j'ai lu, le siège à
Londres euh Jek s'est fait convoquer,
c'est ça ? Ils ont été perquisitionnés
d'après ce que j'ai vu. Ils ont je
crois, il me semble avoir vu ça euh
euh sous réserve he de vérification,
mais il me semble avoir vu ça dans la
presse.
Jucurerbert convoqué par Thesa. Oui,
ils ont alors je sais que effectivement
il y a les plusieurs parlements qui ont
pris des résolutions qui veulent créer
des commissions d'enquête parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre que c'est bon en
deux mots hein le peut-être pour
rappeler les les grandes lignes du
scandale.
Cambridge Analytica, c'est un une
structure de droit anglaise
qui a fait des enquêtes d'opinion sur
Facebook. Alors, je crois, je sais pas
si tu te souviens, mais il y a eu un
partenariat qui a été signé entre plus
c'est plus tordu que ça. [grognement]
C'est qu'en fait c'est un c'est un
chercheur qui a fait des pseudos en
quête d'opinion. ce qui euh tu sais que
du ça peut être c'est du petit sondage
LOL que tu vois sur Facebook et tu fais
"Ouais, je veux l'installer pour faire
le sondage, ça va faire marrer mes
potes." Et en fait quand tu dis "Je veux
installer l'appli" euh tu dis à Facebook
"J'autorise l'appli à pomper mes
données." Donc du coup bah l'appli elle
fait quoi ? Hop, elle pompe tout. pour
peu que tu es pas dit que pour peu que
tous tes potes aient pas mis leur profil
en super fermé et ben du coup ils ont
accès à tes potes et hop là il moissonne
[grognement]
et en fait
euh et en fait ces donnéesl ils s'en
sont resservis ils les ont revendu et
entre autres ils les ont revendu à
Cambridge Analytica qui s'en servent
pour faire du profiling politique du
démarchage de la mise en avant
publicitaire de contenu en fait pour
faire du marketing ciblé simplement
c'est pas pour faire du marketing ciblé
pour de la lessive ou des couches
culottes, ils font du ils font aussi du
marketing ciblé politique et ils
interviennent dans des campagnes. Là où
il y a un effet de brouillard qui est
pas clair, c'est que bien évidemment
quand tu écoutes
en fait quand tu écoutes la boîte de
marketing, elle t'explique que c'est que
ça marche. Elle te dit "Faites appel à
nous et puis cher camarade politique, tu
vas faire 15 points de plus dans les
sondages." Il t'explique que ça marche.
Quand ils vont voir une marque en disant
"On va vous aider à faire de la
publicité ciblée," ils te disent "Tu vas
tripler tes ventes, tu les triples
jamais." Mais c'est ce qu'ils te
vendent. Euh c'est ça qu'ils ont vendu à
à Trump. C'est ça qu'ils ont vendu à la
campagne pour le Brexit en
Grande-Bretagne.
Est-ce que ça a vraiment un effet ?
Ça c'est une autre question. Et tu vois,
c'est pas clair. Est-ce que ça a
vraiment un effet ou est-ce que c'est
juste le côté bravache
des commerciaux de ces boîtes là ? J'en
sais rien. Mais ce dont je suis sûr,
c'est que les données des gens, ils les
ont quand ils ont accepté de transférer
des données, déjà ils pensaient
probablement pas en transférer autant.
Euh et c'était pas dans ce but là,
c'était pour faire un sondage rigolo.
Tout autre usage que le sondage rigolo
est un mésage et est un abut de
confiance.
C'est ça pour moi le point clé, c'est
les gens ont fait confiance,
cette confiance a été trahie et il y
aura pot de balle en sanction.
C'est ça le problème fondamental pour
moi, c'est c'est même pas de savoir si
oui ou non ça a perturbé le scrutin.
Parce que si tu veux tout le monde dans
dans un pays cherche à perturber le
scrutin
pendant une campagne présidentielle en
France. C'est pareil, tout le monde veut
perturber la présidentielle.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, l'analogie
est intéressante, c'est que en France,
le droit électoral et organise cette
campagne et organise la propagande qui a
autour. Euh par exemple, il y a des il y
a des délais euh de à respecter enfin un
peu avant le le scrutin le on n' plus le
droit de faire de de de la propagande
électorale par exemple que d'électoral
l'interdit. Et c'est justement pour
laisser aussi un délai aux électeurs de
réfléchir calmement euh de pas être
assailli de de coup de fil de de
d'affiches de partout de tracte de
démarchage. Euh c'est je pense que dans
une démocratie le processus électoral
nécessite également un encadrement pour
être sincère et loyal un encadrement de
de ces règles. Ces règles doivent rester
équilibrées et on doit respecter un
principe de loyauté. Et c'est ça qui a
été à mon sens euh
dévoyé
totalement dévoyé dans dans cette
affaire.
Attention, ça c'est des règles
française. Aux États-Unis, il y a pas
les mêmes.
C'est vrai. Mais cela dit, le le
principe c'est c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans point de vue juridique,
on est sur la confrontation de deux
types de droits. C'est une campagne
américaine mais la société elle est
basée en Royaume-Uni. Donc ça veut dire
qu'en principe le droit européen était
applicable. Et ce principe-là que dit
Benjamin, le fait que normalement
lorsque des données sont collectées,
elles sont collectées pour et elles sont
on recueille le consentement de la
personne pour un usage en particulier
mais qu'on peut pas ensuite garder ces
données-là et multiplier les usages
derrière. Ça c'est un principe qu'il y a
dans les dans les textes européens.
Donc on verra. Bon je je sais pas du
tout là c'est vraiment prématuré. On
verra dans quelques années le temps que
ça que tout ça se décante. Je sais qu'il
y a un professeur américain qui a euh
attaqué parce que il souhaitait obtenir
l'ensemble des données que Cambridge
[raclement de gorge] Analytica avait sur
lui et je crois que ils ont répondu
uniquement 5 si pages, ce qui n'était
absolument pas révélateur de de des
données qu'ils ont. Et donc il a appris,
je crois un avocat
anglais et il a lancé une procédure pour
essayer de de d'obtenir ces ces
informations. On verra ce que ça donne.
Ça sera la première étape. On verra ce
que donne ensuite l'enquête qui a été
ouverte, la perquisition qui a été
faite, les commissions d'enquête.
Probablement qu'il y aura ensuite des
recours derrière. Mais ce qui est
important, c'est que
on moi cette affaire, elle me fait
penser euh dans la culture populaire
House of Cards, la série américaine.
C'est ça qui se passe dans la
l'avant-dernière ou la dernière saison.
Euh il crée un enfin ils se permettent
d'accéder aux outils de de qui sont là
normalement prévus pour la NSA, pour
lutter contre le terrorisme et ce genre
de choses pour en réalité prendre le pou
de l'opinion et adapter le discours pour
ensuite être réélu. et qu' Analytica,
c'est la même chose. Sauf que là, c'est
pas un outil de la NSA, c'est Facebook
mais c'est peut-être même pire parce que
Facebook a énormément d'information
peut-être peut-être plus.
Facebook c'est un outil de la NSA.
Ouais, ça se défend ça.
J'irai pas jusque là mais pourquoi pas ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Ça se défend pourquoi ? Je pose des
questions bêtes aujourd'hui, tu as vu ?
Euh ça se défend pourquoi ? Une
une des raisons, je pense pour
lesquelles il y a une législation très
peu protectrice des données personnelles
aux États-Unis, c'est en particulier
pour permettre à la NSA de piocher dans
les données des opérateurs américains.
Donc c'est voilà [grognement]
peut-être aussi en plus du renseignement
entraîner leur intelligence
artificielle.
Oui, non, il y a pas forcément besoin de
ça pour pour ça. Mais le
si tu veux pour moi là-dedans, tu as tu
as vraiment un point fondamental qui est
en fait je suis content que l'opinion
publique s'en rende compte mais c'est
pas la première fois, ça fait deux ou
trois fois ces dernières années, que les
gens percutent que en fait Facebook
c'est pas mon pote.
Mais pour moi c'est évident parce que je
suis un vieux con des internets parce
que ça fait 20 ans que
En plus tu es parano et conspi. Donc
non, ça tu confonds, c'est toi. Non non.
Paranoï Conspi, ça
Jean-Michel Conspi, c'est toi. Euh mais
le
chez Facebook, tu es pas le client. Tu
es pas le client,
tu le produis. Ça ça coûte à produire,
ça rapporte de l'argent et c'est pas toi
qui paye. Donc il y a bien quelqu'un qui
paye. Euh c'est pas une œuvre de
charité, c'est pas une association,
c'est pas machin, c'est c'est bien une
entreprise, elle est côté, elle vaut
beaucoup de pognons. Euh donc il y a des
gens qui payent et les gens payent pour
un service. Alors oui, il y a des
contenus publicitaires, il y a pas que
ça. Il y a en fait des contenus
publicitaires ciblés. Et le publicitaire
qui veut cibler, il vient acheter ton
profiling, il vient acheter tout ce
qu'on sait sur toi.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'il faut une loi
pour rendre les algorithmes plus
transparents auprès de ces grandes
boîtes ?
Non,
non, ça sert à rien. C'est du flanc.
L'algorithme plus transparent, ça veut
dire quoi ? On va publier le code, ça
veut pas dire que tu seras moins
manipulé.
En fait, en réalité sur internet, on
peut voir le enfin pour le coup, il y a
déjà au moins une des garanties si le
droit actuel est respecté. Justement, ça
respecte des finalités de la collecte.
Lorsqu'il y a une collecte de données,
un traitement, il est censé être
collecté et traité pour une finalité
donnée. Et normalement, on est censé
consentir à cette finalité là. Et à
partir du moment où vous le faites en en
connaissance de cause, si c'est pas
réutilisé derrière pour d'autres
finalités, et bien c'est suffisamment
protecteur. Le problème qui peut y
avoir, c'est lorsqueun algorithme
utilise des données qui ont été
collectées pour une finalité donné pour
et il utilise pour d'autres finalités.
Et là ça pose un problème parce que là
non seulement on n'a pas connaissance
des finalités qui sont utilisées mais en
plus le fait que ça soit traité par
algorithme ça permet de d'avoir une
force beaucoup plus importante. Les le
le traitement est décuplé les calculs
sont sont enfin c'est pas comme si
c'était un humain derrière qui devait
contrôler et puis cibler tel ou tel
point.
Si tu veux pour pour moi vraiment le
point clé mais fondamental c'est de
réfléchir en
finances en fait. Comment est financé le
service ? Si le service est financé par
quelqu'un qui n'est pas l'utilisateur,
alors le service sert d'autres intérêts
que l'utilisateur final.
Et il faut que [raclement de gorge] ce
soit su, il faut que ce soit affiché, il
faut que ce soit particulièrement
contrôlé voire interdit.
Pour moi, c'est ça le point clé. Je n'ai
rien contre un produit de type Facebook.
Alors si a c'est pour moi techniquement
calamiteux parce que c'est hyper
centralisé. Mais [raclement de gorge] un
produit en rendu utilisateur de type
Facebook où je sais comment c'est
financé parce que c'est moi qui le
finance. Soit je le finance par un
abonnement, soit c'est financé par des
des levées de fond. C'est financé par
des gens qui ont du premium et qui
payent un abonnement et des gens qui
n'ont pas de premium et qui payent et
qui ont un service un petit peu plus
petit. Enfin tu vois ce genre de trucl.
J'ai aucun problème. Mais tant que c'est
financé par quelqu'un et que je suis la
marchandise, c'est malsin. C'est malsin
fondamentalement.
C'était déjà malsin à l'époque où Jean
Dormeon expliquait que je crois que
c'est lui, un ancien patron du Figaro,
mais c'est peut-être le précédent
encore, qui expliquait que le Figaro
pouvait se passer de ses lecteurs
puisque [raclement de gorge] 81 % de ses
revenus venaient de la publicité.
C'était il y a genre 50 ans hein. Et
c'est [grognement] exactement le
discours de
Le lait et moujotte sur TF1 qui explique
que le client c'est Coca-Cola et que la
marchandise c'est le temps de cerveau
disponible. Sauf que
TF1 ne peut pas te cibler toi
individuellement.
Or Facebook peut cibler
individuellement. Facebook peut dire euh
pour on vise euh les femmes françaises
ayant entre 18 et 22 ans euh tel niveau
de diplôme euh telle sexualité, telle
religion euh et cetera et cetera. Enfin,
ils peuvent cibler de manière hyper
fine, euh étant en couple, n'étant pas
en couple, ayant une famille, ayant pas
une famille, enfin tu vois, le ciblage
peut être quasiment nominatif, presque
personne par personne. Et donc, c'est
exactement le même mécanisme malsin de
publicité où tu es la marchandise et non
et non pas le client. Mais en plus, ça
te cible de manière très fine et
potentiellement très manipulatrice parce
que non seulement ça te présente de la
publicité mais ça hiérarchise
l'information pour toi. Et pour moi ça
c'est un critère clé. Dire ils ont
utilisé des données pour des fins
auxquelles tu n'as pas consenti. C'est
un critère du droit actuel. Ça làdessus
est meilleur que moi. Mais pour moi la
vision politique du truc c'est cet
aspect là est fondamentalement vicié.
Alexis.
Ah mais je enfin moi je enfin je suis je
suis assez
inquiet de des possibilités qu'il
peuvent y avoir.
Alors sois pas trop inquiet parce que
sinon tu vas passer pour un conspit.
Non [grognement] je je enfin en tout cas
disons, je pense qu'il faut qu'on reste
vigilant parce que ce genre de scandale
montre que
c'est c'est un combat de chaque instant.
En réalité euh le glissement est très
vite réalisé.
Euh et c'est pas parce qu'on pense qu'on
est suffisamment protégé en Europe qu'en
réalité on l'est effectivement sur une
celle un peu plus globale parce que les
droits sont différents. Euh et par
exemple tout à l'heure Benjamin dit
quelque chose d'intéressant, c'est il
faut bien garder à l'esprit que en
Europe, on a une conception assez euh
assez large des droits. Ça veut dire que
le droit des données personnelles, il
protège l'ensemble des données
personnelles.
Alors avec des critères bien sûr de il
s'applique au traitement qui sont
réalisés sur le territoire ou par des
personnes qui réalisent le traitement
sur le territoire. Enfin bon, il y a des
ce genre ce type de critère. Mais si
vous êtes un étranger euh qui communique
avec enfin qui a des communications soit
qui passent sur le territoire ou soit
qui communique avec le avec le l'Union
européenne, vos données vos données sont
protégées de la même manière.
à partir du moment où si vous c'est pas
uniquement le critère de la nationalité
qui rentre en compte, c'est un c'est
beaucoup plus large, une application qui
est beaucoup plus large. Aux États-Unis,
c'est un petit peu différent. Ils ont
quand même une conception qui est très
attachée de la protection des droits aux
Américains et au territoire américain.
Et le problème, c'est que quand nos
donné elle transit et arrivent au point
de contact aux États-Unis, on n pas la
protection de la nationalité américaine.
Et le au moment où ça rentre sur le
territoire, c'est c'est là où
c'est vraiment balou. Non, mais
ce que ce que j'essaie de dire, c'est
que euh et c'est ça un petit peu ce qui
gêne aussi par exemple dans le privacy
Shield, c'est que euh les les recours
qui existent éventuellement en droit
interne souvent ne sont ouverts en fait
que aux Américains parce que euh il faut
ensuite aller devant des autorités
américaines, il faut connaître un peu le
droit américain. C'est pas les les ce ce
qui est prévu aujourd'hui n'est pas
vraiment effectif. C'est c'est ça un des
problèmes, c'est que en tant
qu'européen, on a on a des conceptions
différentes du droit, on a des
conceptions différentes de la procédure
et on n'est pas habitué. Et aujourd'hui,
un un avocat européen qui devrait par
exemple défendre
un Européen aux États-Unis, bon déjà il
y aurait des problèmes de compétence
mais en plus il aurait du mal à s'y
retrouver en réalité.
Tu es en train de me dire que la
l'Europe a perdu totalement sa
souveraineté.
Non, c'est justement c'est c'est pas ce
que je suis en train de dire. Je suis en
train de dire que l'Europe doit être
vigilante pour ne pas la perdre. Et il y
a un autre cas comme ça qui est qui est
assez amusant, c'est le cas des Warren
Case euh devant la Cour suprême des
États-Unis avec Microsoft.
Euh pour en en deux mots, hein, c'est le
les autorités américaines avaient
demandé euh à Microsoft de pouvoir
accéder à des emails qui étaient stockés
en Irlande.
Oui. Oui. Beau ça.
Et Microsoft a refusé. Heureusement,
c'est d'abord passé. Donc il y a eu une
procédure, il y a eu une un une affaire
qui est passée devant des juridictions
au niveau euh des circuits de courtes
aux États-Unis. C'est une certaine
juridiction. Je crois que Microsoft a
gagné la première fois de mémoire et
ensuite l'affaire a été renvoyée devant
la Cour suprême des États-Unis qui a
accepté de de l'étudier parce que c'est
pas automatique hein. La Course suprême
n'étudie que certaines affaires
lorsqu'elles considèrent que c'est
suffisamment important ou intéressant.
Combien de
juges la Cour suprême ? On a neuf de
mémoire il me semble neuf juges qui sont
nommés par le président
ils sont nommés à
à nommé nomination à c'est différent en
France on connait on a connaît pas ce
système de nomination
qui a à la fois une garantie hein cela
dit hein parce qu'une fois que vous êtes
nommé vous pouvez plus être délogé
et donc l'affaire est en cours et il y a
tout un tas d'intervenants qui sont qui
ont présenté dans des interventions
notamment paradoxalement la commission
européenne. Je crois que l'État
français, mais ça je suis pas certain,
je crois que l'État français est
intervenu aussi, mais la commission,
c'est sûr. Et
et donc la question qui se pose, c'est
une question de souveraineté parce que
c'est la question de savoir si des
emails qui sont stockés dans un pays
étranger, bon là c'est un pays européen,
l'Irlande,
peuvent faire l'objet d'une injonction
américaine sans passer par des
procédures européennes ou Irlandaises.
Tu as entendu parler du Cloud Act ou
quelque chose qui ressemble à ça ? Non,
j'ai j'ai pas vu le je vois pas tout ce
que c'est ça. J'ai
Donald Trump s'en frotter les mains
paraît-il.
Je je vraiment là ça me dit des
étrangers. Bon, on refera une autre
émission pour parler de ça.
À moins que Corben se manifeste sur le
Discord.
Est-ce que vous avez des conseils pour
limiter le siphonage de tout ça ?
l'analyse économique.
L'analyse économique, c'est choisir euh
quand tu quand tu veux choisir ta
plateforme,
euh je prends je prends un exemple qui
est très simple parce que ça çaen est un
où il y a une une vraie solution euh qui
est le microblogging.
Euh évite Twitter et va sur Mastodon.
Pourquoi ? Parce que Mastodon, c'est il
doit y avoir quelque chose comme 2000
serveurs agrégés qui forment le réseau.
Chaque serveur a son mode de financement
propre et donc quand tu crées ton compte
sur un serveur, tu sais par qui il est
opéré. Tu sais que je sais pas Mamode.fr
il est géré par la quadrature du net. Tu
sais que Mastodon. X Y Z, celui où j'ai
mon compte, il est géré par un gars qui
est The Kin Rar euh et que en fait tu
sais comment c'est financé quoi. Euh le
mec il est étudiant et il a je sais plus
si un patréon, un tipi, un truc comme ça
et et il récupère 150 € tous les mois
pour payer le serveur et puis voilà.
[grognement] Et tu sais comment ça
tourne.
Euh et en fait ça c'est structurant. Si
tu sais pas comment c'est financé et si
c'est financé par quelqu'un qui n'est
pas toi,
ça veut dire que ils n'hésiteront pas à
te faire du tort.
C'est qu'ils vont pas défendre tes
intérêts. C'est pas toi le client.
Quand c'est financé parce que tu payes
un abonnement ou parce que c'est une
association et que les adhérents de
l'association financent le truc. Le
mamode.fr de la quadrature, c'est la
quadrature qui finance. Ça coûte pas
très cher, ça coûte un serveur et un
tout petit peu de temps, c'est Pinuts.
Mais on sait comment c'est financé.
C'est la quadrature qui finance et on a
pas besoin de publicité pour financer.
Et ça c'est pour moi un élément clé dans
l'analyse. Tu veux héberger des mails et
bah évite Gmail, va prendre n'importe
quelle solution de mail dont tu sais
comment c'est financé et dont tu sais de
quoi ça vit. Si tu sais pas de quoi ça
vit, c'est que tu as un problème. Tu
prends une boîte payante, tu prends une
boîte gérée par une association, tu
prends ce que tu veux, mais un truc dont
tu sais comment c'est financé et que
c'est pas financé contre tes intérêts.
Et pour moi, c'est ça devient un angle
d'analyse vital.
Alexis,
tu utilises quoi comme service ?
Comme service en ligne,
internet, boîte mail. Alors, j'en
utilise j'en utilise beaucoup et
notamment j'utilise certains de boîtes
américaines, mais je sais que les
informations qui sont dessus ne doivent
pas être des informations
confidentielles des informations
sensibles. Euh donc moi, j'ai je fais le
choix il y a longtemps euh lorsque j'ai
décidé la question qui se posait c'était
soit ne plus du tout utiliser services
américains, entreprise américaine, soit
au contraire euh les utiliser de manière
raisonnée. Et moi, à titre personnel,
c'est le choix que j'ai fait, mais je
suis parfaitement conscient que
l'ensemble des données que j'ai, par
exemple, sur mon compte Twitter euh sont
euh ne doivent pas enfin mon compte
Twitter ne doit pas détenir de données
sensibles euh que ça soit les tweets
publics mais même les DM par exemple. Je
ton téléphone portable. Non, al c'est la
même idée. Après il y a des solutions de
chiffrement sur téléphone portable que
que j'utilise par exemple.
Lesquels ?
Moi j'en utilise plusieurs mais
signal, télégramou
silent phone, des choses comme ça.
Ouais.
Benjamin, tu utilises Twitter toi ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Alors,
abondamment. Abondamment. Tu
les un toxique ? Tu empoisonne tes
données ?
Non, j'empoisonne j'empoisonne pas mes
données. Je sais ce que j'en fais.
C'estd que j'utilise très très peu
Twitter à titre à titre privé. J'utilise
essentiellement Twitter. Alors, j'ai un
compte privé dessus mais qui est
quasiment mort. Mais mon [grognement]
compte public euh si tu regardes 90 % de
ce que je raconte, je viens en fait
parler au grand public et il se trouve
que voilà, il y a 16000 personnes qui me
suivent ou quelque chose comme ça sur
Twitter et que j'ai des choses à leur
dire et j'utilise ça comme outil, comme
porte-voie parce que j'ai pas de
porte-voie plus puissant à ma
disposition. Mais j'ai aussi un compte
Mastodon où je où je raconte des choses
plus intéressantes, parfois un peu plus
perso. Euh j'ai un peu moins de gens qui
me suivent mais il y en a quand même
beaucoup. Ils sont un peu plus de 3000.
C'est les meilleurs.
Oui, bien sûr. Mais ceux-là, j'ai plus
besoin de les convaincre si tu veux.
J'ai plus besoin de leur expliquer
pourquoi il y a besoin de sortir de
tout.
Tu chiffres un peu. Non. Tu chiffres
avec quoi ?
Alors, j'ai toujours horreur de
chiffrer. Euh, j'aime pas ça. Ça me fait
chier. Mais ça me fait chier autant que
de mettre une serrure sur ma porte. Ça
me gonfle. J'ai juste envie que mon
voisin rentre pas chez moi sans avoir
frappé à la porte. J'ai pas envie de
mettre une serrure pour n'en empêcher.
C'est comme ça. Moi, je suis je suis
comme ça. Je suis un gentil. J'estime
que mon voisin il doit être bien élevé.
En moyenne, il l'est. Et que donc
tu es un gentil toi.
Bien sûr, je suis quelqu'un de très
doux. [rires]
[raclement de gorge] Faut juste pas me
faire chier. Mais
mais c'est vrai, ça me fait chier de
chiffrer, ça me gonfle. Euh mais il
n'empêche que bah maintenant toutes les
communications de mon ordinateur passent
par un VPN. Euh c'est du open VPN. Alors
c'est entre autres c'est parce que la
fibre optique chez moi c'est orange et
que mon FAI ne peut pas fournir de fibre
optique parce que le marché de la fibre
est verrouillé en France que donc pour
avoir mon IPF FDN j'ai un VPN et du coup
tout ce qui passe sur la fibre orange
chez moi est chiffré. [grognement] De
fait pas spécialement fait exprès, mais
je trouve c'est plutôt mieux. Euh
donc voilà ça tout ça c'est chiffré.
J'ai quelques mails chiffrés mais c'est
marginal. C'est vraiment marginal.
Il y a Virginie qui est en train de se
s'endormir. Tu veux dire quelque chose ?
Non non non, je suis bien.
Est-ce que tu as Est-ce que tu as noté
des choses que tu veux qu'on traite ?
Non. D'accord.
On te mettra un micro la prochaine fois.
Alors pour les pour les pour les gens
qui regardent et qui suivent pas,
Virginie, c'est une des exégettes
amateurs qui est venue avec nous et qui
a pas osé prendre la parole en public et
qui est en train de qui est très active
en ce moment sur Orange Fail où il y a
un mémoire qu'on dépose ces jours-ci en
réplique au gouvernement. Et voilà. Donc
comme on allait parler du dossier mais
voilà, elle a préféré ne pas prendre de
micro.
On arrive vers la fin. Euh on a pour
habitude de laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations. Alors comme Benjamin
est habitué, on va lui donner la parole
tout de suite. On va laisser Alexis
réfléchir à son conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Il faut que tu imagines ça
comme une bouteille à la mer. un conseil
qui va essayer de de résister au temps.
Benjamin,
ben écoute, je reste je reste assez
d'avis de ce que je de ce que j'avais
dit la dernière fois sur mon mon
conseil, tu vois. J'ai pas tellement
changé d'avis. Faites des choses. Faites
des choses. Passionnez-vous. Lisez,
apprenez, faites des choses. On s'en
fout quoi. Devenez très bon en planche à
voile ou en cornemuse ou en faisage de
pain ou en en ce que vous voulez. Mais
faites des choses. Arrêtez d'être
passif. Faites des choses.
Passionnez-vous. Bougez. Euh on s'en
fout si c'est pas dans la norme, on s'en
fout si c'est pas il y a pas besoin
d'être startuper quoi. Tu vois, c'est
pas le deal. Mais faites des trucs,
faites des trucs vivants.
Euh, il y a rien de plus important en
fait. Tout le reste passera. Faites des
choses vivante. Laiss Ne soyez pas
passif face au monde. Le monde est celui
que vous faites. Pas forcément en
militant. Enfin, si c'est bien. Enfin,
pas forcément en manifestant. Enfin, si
c'est bien. Mais pas que. Quand tu
décides que tu fais ton petit monde avec
tes potes selon tes règles. Ouais.
Ouais. vous les les 18 que vous êtes là
euh [grognement]
c'est quoi mon prénom déjà ?
Engéran ou Jean ? Je sais plus. Non, toi
tu es Jean-Michel complotiste, ça te va
très bien.
Non, conspire, ça c'est tu vois le truc,
c'est ça, c'est faites des choses, soyez
faiseur. Ça veut pas forcément dire
grand entrepreneur. J'ai euh si si ta
vie c'est d'aller écouter, pousser les
pack crêes, c'est vachement bien comme
activité.
Euh si ta vie c'est d'aller euh d'aller
voir d'aller faire pousser trois chèvres
en profitant du paysage dans le Cantal,
c'est vachement bien comme activité. Tu
tu vois le truc ?
Mais juste rester assis à passivement
ingurgiter TF1 ou ce que Facebook veut
bien te vendre comme propagande,
c'est triste.
Alexis,
moi je pense que je conseilleraiis
d'être curieux sur sur le fonctionnement
du monde qui nous entoure.
Alors là, bon, le thème d'aujourd'hui,
c'est touche le numérique et le
juridique. C'est un je conseillerai de
commencer par là, mais également le
reste et de rester vigilant et de voir
comment les choses fonctionnent de point
de vue numérique, du point de vue
juridique. Ça permet ensuite de mieux
savoir se défendre et de savoir comment
répondre éventuellement à certaines
menaces. Des menaces qui peuvent nous
priver d'une partie de notre libre
arbitre. euh de nous imposer des
manières de penser, de
s'insinuer en réalité dans ce ce qu'on a
de profond en nous, de plus profond de
notre façon de voir le monde, notre
manière de penser.
Donc oui, je pense que si s'il y avait
un conseil à donner, ça serait ça serait
de rester curieux sur le fonctionnement
du monde et notamment sur tout ce qui
permet autour de de rester vigilant sur
certaines menaces. J'en profite pour
pour vous poser une question à tous les
deux d'ailleurs. On a déconné avec
Jean-Michel Conspi et tout ça. Est-ce
que vous avez des des préconisations
pour lutter pour les fake news, les
théories conspirationnistes sur
internet, cette perte cette perte de
d'esprit critique que le le net de temps
en temps véhicule ?
Vous avez des préconisations face à ça ?
Enfin, c'est c'est une question qui est
assez difficile. Moi, je pense que le
l'esprit critique, c'est quelque chose
qui l'école aide à le construire.
L'éducation, l'école c'est quelque chose
qui est assez fondamental et après c'est
quelque chose qui ne s'use lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on ne s'en sert pas. C'est
quelque chose qui est renouvelé tous les
jours. En réalité, l'esprit critique,
c'est à chaque fois à chaque fois que
vous êtes confronté à une situation qui
est un tout petit peu même n'importe
quelle situation en réalité, il faut
toujours se poser la question de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'il est vraiment en train de
se passer, quel est l'objectif derrière,
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train d'essayer
de me dire, quel est le message,
pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut on veut me
faire passer ce message là ? Qu'est-ce
qu'on attend de moi ? Quelle est la
réaction que je devrais avoir ?
et puis voilà, réfléchir de cette
manière-là, de manière un peu logique et
dépassionné, on les sent peut-être un
petit peu les réactions
émotives qui peut qu'on peut avoir mais
qui sont tout à fait naturels, c'est
notre humanité. Mais je pense qu'à un
moment donné, il faut dire bon stop, je
m'arrête, je réfléchis.
Ouais, ça c'est un
et je j'avais lu des papiers super
intéressants là-dessus. C'est un biais
de euh en fait de toutes les plateformes
qui vivent de publicité. Elles ont
besoin de créer de l'engagement. Or, tu
es beaucoup plus engagé quand tu es
quand tu es pas content.
Donc il faut qu'on mette des choses qui
vont te mettre en colère. Euh faut pas
mettre du contenu apaisant, il faut pas
mettre du contenu rassurant, il faut
mettre du contenu qui te qui t'énerve.
Du simple et court.
Pas forcément. Ça peut même être très
long. C'est c'est rien. C'est le décor
qui se casse la gueule. Ça fait des
bruits bizarres à côté. Euh le pas
forcément simple les cours, ça peut être
très long au contraire. Euh mais on te
met des choses énervantes et punchy et
dur et provocatrices pour que ça
t'énerve.
Euh et donc le but de ces plateformes
est de te poser et de te proposer des
contenus de plus en plus trash et de
plus en plus violents. C'est ce qu'on
voit à la télévision he la télévision
cherche à te pousser vers plus trash
pour que tu restes pour que tu sois
énervé euh parce que du coup tu regardes
la publicité.
Et en fait un bon moyen de de de réagir
à ça, c'est juste de le savoir, de
savoir qu'on est en train de te
manipuler et qu'on te qu'on te montre un
monde violent alors qu'il ne l'est pas.
On nous fait croire par exemple qu'il y
a énormément de violence terroristes en
France alors qu'il y en a très peu. Il y
a beaucoup plus de violence politique il
y a 40 ans en France qu'aujourd'hui.
Euh les ministres ne meurent pas d'un
pseudo accident de voiture dans les dans
un étant aujourd'hui hein. Robert Boulin
il est mort comme ça.
Tu fais référence à côté de Mfort la
moris c'est ça ? Non, il est dans les
gens. Non,
je sais plus dans quel coin il est mort
Boulin mais enfin tu vois c'est il y a
pas eu de ministre assassiné en France
depuis très longtemps. Donc la l'air de
rien, la violence politique est plus
faible. Euh la violence policière est
plus forte mais tu vois, on essaie de te
faire croire que le monde est violent
alors qu'il l'est pas. Euh
et ça c'est un effet de manipulation et
c'est effectivement les fake news font
ça. Alors les vrais fake news, tu sais
c'est c'est l'article qui qui dit un
truc qui existe pas, tu vois qui est
Donald Trump mange des petits enfants au
petit-déjeuner. Tu vois truc existe pas
mais tu publies ça avec une photo bien
putacière.
Tu vas faire tu tu vas faire de la
diffusion sur Facebook, tu vas faire de
l'audience avec ça alors que tout est
faux dedans. C'est c'est même pas un un
journaliste qui s'est trompé, tu vois.
C'est c'est fait pour être faux. C'est
juste fait pour que tu cliques.
Et c'est juste fait pour créer de
l'engagement, pour t'énerver, pour que
tu dises "Ah mais quelle connerie !" Euh
et en fait, on va sortir les
monstruosités les plus grosses pour que
tu réagisses. Et et Facebook, même pas
forcément intentionnellement, mais parce
que c'est l'algorithme qui fait monter
l'audience et donc qui fait monter le
revenu publicitaire, prome ça de manière
automatique ou dirigée, je sais pas
trop. Mais un subtile mélange des deux.
Attention Jean-Michel hein, je te je te
surveille.
Pas dirigé au sens où ils choisirent les
trucs les plus trashes he mais au sens
où ils ont tuné l'algorithme pour qu'il
fonctionne comme ça parce que ça monte
mieux. Euh
et donc ça une fois que tu sais, tu le
sens, c'est tu sens que là tu es en
train de regarder ça et c'est en train
de t'énerver. Typiquement dans il y a
des tas de situations dans lesquelles
Twitter je sens c'est en train de
m'énerver, je ferme, je me mets
n'importe quoi, une série de la musique
machin, je vais faire du crochet, de la
lecture,
n'importe quoi et je redeviens z mais
très très vite en fait. Et je pense que
ça c'est un élément assez facile pour
résister qui est sentir le moment où on
te manipule et où on est en train de
t'énerver et de t'aspirer euh parce
qu'on te en fait on te fait agir sur du
patos.
Euh on fait appel aux émotions les plus
violentes et donc on tape sur la colère,
on tape sur l'envie, on tape sur la
haine
éventuellement sur l'amour.
Euh si on fait appel à tes à tes bons
sentiments, par exemple du dégoulinant
de bons sentiments sur Facebook, il y en
a des tonnes. On fait appel à des
émotions fortes et primitives. Et on
fait absolument pas appel à la raison,
on fait absolument pas appel à l'esprit
critique, on fait absolument pas appel à
l'analyse. Et ça, avec un tout petit peu
d'habitude, tu sens quand on te manipule
et du coup, tu veux plus, tu fais "OK,
pour ce soir, je ferme, je vais faire
autre chose."
Merci pour ces petits conseils. Je
voudrais trois bouquins chacun à
conseiller à la communauté.
Waouh ! Allez ! Hop hop
sur le sujet ou
non qui vous passe par la tête et on
terminera là-dessus.
Allez, je vais je vais en sortir un de
science-fiction, le successeur de pierre
euh de Jean-Michel ou Jean-Pierre
Truang, je sais plus. Très très bon
bouquin de science-fiction. Euh un qui
n'a rigoureusement aucun rapport et qui
va parler de typographie, le fontes et
codage de Yanis Aralambous chez Oriley
qui est pas une traduction qui est
vraiment un bouquin écrit en français
[grognement]
qui n'est plus édité mais qui se trouve
encore d'occasion qui est un très bon
livre pour les gens qui aiment un peu la
typographie électronique. Euh et puis je
vais bien t'en trouver un troisième.
Bah tu vas au moins toi te connaissant
tu vas tu veux dire le comité invisible
l'insurrection qui vient. Ah non, aucun
intérêt. Euh aucun intérêt. Euh alors
soit celui dont je parlais tout à
l'heure tiens de George Balandier,
anthropologie politique, mais je l'ai
pas encore lu, donc je me sens pas bien
de le recommander. Euh
le traité de la servitude volontaire de
Étienne de la Boie.
Bien vu.
C'est
ça suffit là.
C'est tout petit he ça fait mais c'est
c'est microscopique le traité de la
servitude volontaire. Il y a peut-être
40 pages, ça vaut ça existe en édition à
2 €. Ça se lit en 1 heure. C'est super
intéressant écrit en 1400 et des
bricoles par un mec qui avait 18 balais
quoi. Intéressant.
Alexis,
c'est difficile.
Je conseillerais
le
Non, justement pas surtout pas de de
bouquin juridique. Euh
c'est moi les enfin bon allez, il y en a
un que que je conseillerai qui s'appelle
Saint-Germain ou la négociation. Euh je
crois que l'auteur le nom de l'auteur
c'est Francis Valder avec un W qui est
un livre très intéressant qui se passe
dans un contexte historique mais qui
explique un petit peu les mécanismes de
négociation et donc de manipulation
puisque la négociation est une
manipulation et c'est très bien écrit et
très accessible. Je je le recommande
chaudement.
Euh je recommande également aller dans
la dans la fantaisie. Moi, j'ai été
beaucoup marqué par les les livres de
Robin Hub. notamment toute la saga de
l'assassin royale que j'aime beaucoup et
que je relis régulièrement depuis que je
suis ados. Euh
et après c'est difficile là, c'est bon,
ça c'est suffisant,
c'est suffisant. Je vous on vous
remercie beaucoup et on vous dit à la
prochaine et et on remercie tous nos
tipers, toute notre communauté d'être
derrière nous tout le temps et on les
embrasse fort et on les aime. Passez une
bonne soirée. Merci à vous
de fin.
[musique]